THAT AFTERNOON I WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE TO THE STATE
CAPITOL INTO THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CAMPUS CLIMATE.
THIS IS THE FIRST CAMPUS
CLIMATE HEARING FOR THE TWENTY
SEVEN. A TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
I WON EXTEND MY APPRECIATION TO
THE PALACE WILL BE HERE TODAY IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO TOOK TIME OUT
OF THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES THIS
AFTERNOON TO SHARE VALUABLE
INSIGHTS.
ABOUT VITAL ISSUESCONCERNING
OCCURRING ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND UNIVERSITIES.
IF ME OUT THERE ARE VARIOUS
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE COMING IN
AND OUT THE OTHER HEARINGS
HADN'T AND MEETINGS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE AT THE CAPITOL SO
SOME OF THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE.
SELECT COMMITTEE MAY BE COMING
IN.
AT DIFFERENT TIMES WE LOOK FOR
TO THEY ALL HAVE RECEIVED
INFORMATION AND MANY OF THEM
WILL BE WATCHING THE HEARINGS IN
THEIR OFFICES.
THIS IS OUR FOURTH YEAR HOSTING
HEARINGS ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CAMPUS CLIMATE.
MANY OF YOU MAY REMEMBER WHEN
.
IT'S FOUR YEARS AGO THOSE
BECAUSE OF AN UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT THAT WAS HAPPENING SAN
JOSE STATE.
AND THE THE ISSUE AT THAT POINT
WAS RACE. AND OF THE KIND OF
OVERSIGHT OF A LACK OF OVERSIGHT
AND SUPPORT STUDENTS RECEIVING
ON THAT PARTICULAR CAMPUS.
AS A RESULT OF THAT THIS COULD
THIS PSALM.
SELECT COMMITTEE WAS FORMED BY
THEY'VE BEEN SPEAKER JOHN PEREZ
WHO ASKED ME TO CHAIR OF THE. A
CAMPUS CLIMATE COMMITTEE.
SINCE THEN.
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO ADDRESS
THE VARIOUS ISSUES THAT AFFECT
STUDENTS.
WHETHER STEVEN WITH ISSUES OF
RACE OR GENDER.
OR IS ANTICIPATED SUBMIT AND I
SUBMIT BEHAVIOR UCLA WHILE WE
GOT A CROWN THE STATE RAISING
ISSUES OF OF CONCERN.
TODAY'S TOPIC IS ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS IN THE PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SECTOR.
AND IT'S NOT AN UNFAMILIAR
TOPIC TO MANY OF YOU BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE AND DOING AS I WANT TO SAY
REALLY IN A FANTASTIC JOB.
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE HELD ITS VERY FIRST
HEARING AT SENDING STATE
UNIVERSITY ON STUDENT FOOD
INSECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAD NO IDEA THAT AT THAT TIME
THAT IT WOULD BECOME SUCH A
MAJOR ISSUE. OF THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BUT WE HAVE BEEN
APPROACHED ABOUT IT BECAUSE
ACTUALLY.
HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSECURITY HAS A PROFOUND IMPACT
ON THE LIFE OF STUDENTS AND
UPLAND OBVIOUSLY THE CLIMATE THE
CAMPUS ITSELF IN TERMS OF HOW
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
MATRICULATED. FROM ONE YEAR TO
THE NEXT EXCESSIVELY IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE AND SO THAT IS A MAJOR
CONCERN IS THERE. WE HEARD FROM
STUDENTS AND CAMPUS OFFICIALS
FROM SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
AROUND THE SAN DIEGO AREA THAT
EXPOSED US TO HOW DIFFICULT IT
WAS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. SOMETIMES ON
CAMPUSES BECAUSE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE ALL
THE RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT
GOVERN US.
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING BECAUSE
DURING THAT TIME AS A RESULT WE
UNCOVERED A LOT OF THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED WHETHER
IT WAS DEALING WITH THE FOOD
BANKS AND MAKING IT POSSIBLE.
FOR CAMPUSES TO ACTUALLY GET
FOOD FROM FOOD BANKS SINCE THEY
WORK NONPROFIT AGENCIES OR
WHETHER IT'S.
LOOKING THE CAMPUS IS A WE HAVE
TO HAVE A BILL THIS YEAR THIS
LOOKING AT ALL CAMPUSES THAT
DON'T HAVE CAO FRESH PROGRAMS IN
THEIR COUNTIES. AND HOW DO WE
GET THOSE CAL FRESH OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE SO WE HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT OPEN IT UP OPENS IT UP FOR
THOSE WHO. ACTUALLY GET OF CAO
FRESH FROM STATE AND IF THERE
COUNTY DOESN'T HAVE IT.
SO THIS YEAR.
WE FOUND THAT SO TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS SURVEYED
GO OUT NEARLY ONE IN FOUR HAVE
FOOD AND SECURITIES. AND THE
SAME STUDY ALSO SHOWED THE TEN
PERCENT OF C. ISSUE STUDENTS
WERE HOMELESS.
THE UC STUDY SHOWED THAT NEARLY
ONE OF FIVE STUDENTS AT ISSUES
WITH FOOD INSECURITY. A YEAR AGO
INTO A SIXTEEN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE THOUGH IT GIVES AN
UPDATE ON WHAT SOME OF THE C.
ISSUES AND YOU SEE SAID I HAVE
BEEN DOING AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY. TO ALSO GET AN
ADDITIONAL UPDATE.
SINCE THE STUDY THERE HAS BEEN
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF ATTENTION
TO THE BASIC NEEDS OF STUDENTS
WITH THE SEGMENTS RESPONDING IN
VARIOUS WAYS.
STUDENTS STAFF AND FACULTY LIKE
HAVE GALVANIZED AND RALLIED
AROUND THESE ISSUES AND I FIND A
VERY HARD THING TO.
THOUGH THERE STUDENTS HAVE TAKEN
THE LEAD IN TAKING THE CHARGE.
IF ONE OF THE IDEAS OF CAMPUS
CLIMATE IS TO PROVIDE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT PROMOTES AND
SUSTAINS ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
THEN IMPROVING INSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSES TO THESE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY A
RELEVANT.
OUR PREFERENCE MOST OF OUR
CAMPUS CLIMATE MEETINGS ESTATE
AGAIN FOR THIS ONE THIS IS NOT A
HEARING DESIGNATED TO LAMB BASS
ANY CAMPUS OR SYSTEM. HOWEVER IT
IS A HEARING TO AND INTIMATE TO
TO FIND OUT WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT AND HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE IT. WE BELIEVE THAT MANY
OF YOU WILL BE INSPIRED BY THE
HEARING THINGS TO HEAR TODAY
ABOUT THE VARIOUS CAMPUSES.
IT HAS BEEN TO USE AS A SET
SINCE WE'VE DONE AN UPDATE HERE
THE CAPITAL AND WAS ONLY A
THROUGH THAT PANEL WITH THREE
SECONDS OF STUDENTS THAT WILL BE
GAVE. ABLE TO NOTIFY IDENTIFY
THE VARIOUS NEEDS.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO
DIVE DEEPER INTO THE CC BUT
THROUGH COLLEGES A C. ISSUES IN
THE UC SYSTEM AND STE AND GET
THIS CAMPUS I'M A STUDENTS
PERSPECTIVE OF. ON THIS LONG
STANDING PROBLEM THAT WE FACE.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY ONE OF OUR
OUR.
MEMBERS OF THE CAMPUS CLIMATE
COMMITTEE AND I'LL GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU WANT TO SAY
HELLO MISS TO MEDINA WHO'S AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
IN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MR
MEDINA.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER AYE I
WOULD JUST SAY WELCOME AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
STUDENTS.
ON THIS VERY SERIOUS ISSUE THAT
IS.
VERY MUCH A PRESSING.
PROBLEM AND I KNOW ON OUR
CAMPUSES AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WE ID HAVE A CHANCE AS
WELL TO. HEAR ABOUT THE ISSUE.
AND SAID TO PUBLIC DAYS AGO.
AND AS WE HAVE HEARD.
ABOUT IT AS WELL.
I IN ALL OUR VISITS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WELCOME ALL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA CALL OF OUR FIRST
FANDOM JUST RULES WE WILL EACH
PRESENT IT WILL HAPPEN.
APPROX WE FIVE MINUTES MAYBE SIX
OF THE GOES OVER.
AND AT THE END OF EACH OF THE
PANELS I WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE LEGISLATORS.
AT THE TOWARD THE END OF THE
HEARING AFTER WE'VE HEARD FROM
THREE PANELS AND WE'LL OPEN IT
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
I NEEDED THAT POINT EACH PUBLIC
GO COMMENT PURSE WILL HAVE OF. A
MINUTE TO BASICALLY OF EITHER
ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS
CONCERNING THAT WHAT THEY'VE
HEARD.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH DOING
A BY SYSTEM SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE TODAY TO
HAVE WITH US COLEEN GANLEY WHO
AMOR EVERMAN. WHO IS THE?
WHO'S FROM IS FROM THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE CHANCES
OFFICE.
WE HAVE NANCY GRASS WHOSE
ASSOCIATE DEAN OF SANTA MONICA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND ALI
HUNDRED LOOK. NO MELODIES SHE
HERE.
OKAY HE I'M SORRY OF THE LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE SO EVERYONE'S
HERE WITHIN A BEGAN.
AND.
HERE FROM A CO LEAD I THINK.
.
WHEN WE GET TO ONE MAN IF YOU
WILL GET US A SIGN SAYING YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE LEFT. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU.
GOOD OUT GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRWOMAN WEBER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT TODAY'S
HEARING. AND THANKS TO YOU AND
OTHER LEGISLATORS WHO PROVIDED
LEGISLATIVE AND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR THE BASIC NEEDS OF
STUDENTS. MY NAME IS CALLING
GALLIUM A SPECIALIST WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE MY WORK FOCUSES ON
SUPPORTS.
FOR BASIC NEEDS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS INCLUDING FOOD
HOUSING HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. WITH IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SEVENTY TWO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS WITH
A HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND WE SERVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS.
AND WHILE WE DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE STATEWIDE STINT STATISTICS
SPECIFICALLY FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WE DO
KNOW BASED ON NATIONAL RESEARCH
CONDUCTED BY THE WISCONSIN HOPE
LAB THAT TWO OUT OF THREE
STUDENTS SURVEYED. REPORT BEING
FOOD INSECURE FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE STUDENTS REPORT BEING
HOUSING INSECURE AND THIRTEEN
REPORT BEING HOMELESS. IN
CALIFORNIA THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
CONDUCTED THE SYSTEM WIDE FOOD
HOUSING SURVEY ACROSS THEIR
STUDENT BODY.
SIXTY TO OF THE RESPONDENTS
REPORTED BEING FOOD INSECURE
FIFTY FIVE REPORTED BEING
HOUSING INSECURE. AND ALMOST
NINETEEN PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS
SURVEYED AND IT WAS CLOSE TO
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS REPORTED
BEING HOMELESS SO I FIND THAT
RATHER STAGGERING.
IN AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
HAS ENGAGED IN A NUMBER OF
ACTIVITIES TO SUPPORT THE
COLLEGES AS THEY WORK TO SUPPORT
THE BASIC NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS.
WE ARE SO PLEASED TO HAVE JUST
HOSTED THE FIRST EVER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BASIC NEEDS
SUMMIT. NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
FACULTY STAFF AND ADMINISTRATORS
ATTENDED THIS EVENT TO LEARN
ABOUT BEST PRACTICES AND
STRATEGIES IN SUPPORTING THE
BASIC NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
IN PREPARATION WE WE DO HOPE TO
MAKE THIS AN ANNUAL OR BIANNUAL
EVENT IN PREPARATION FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE HUNGER FREE
CAMPUS CAMPAIGN WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM. THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
CONDUCTED A SYSTEM WIDE SURVEY
REGARDING REGARDING FOOD
SECURITY RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS. NINETY TWO OF THE
COLLEGES HUNDRED FIVE OF THE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RESPONDED.
SIXTY EIGHT PERCENT REPORTED THE
AVAILABILITY OF CAMPUS BASED
FOOD PANTRIES.
FORTY EIGHT PERCENT REPORT HAVE
REPORTED ONGOING COLLABORATION
WITH THEIR LOCAL FOOD BANKS AND
ALMOST SIXTY TWO PERCENT
REPORTED THE AVAILABILITY OF
SUPPORT SERVICES TO STUDENTS
COMPLETING CAO FRESH
APPLICATIONS.
WE USED THIS SURVEY DATA TO
DEVELOP A BEST PRACTICES GUIDE
WHICH WE CAN PROVIDE TO YOU
ELECTRONICALLY AND WILL BE
DOING.
DISSEMINATE ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
EARLY NEXT WEEK.
A IN TERMS OF DISTRIBUTING THE
HUNGER FREE CAMPUS FUNDS WE
UTILIZED EXISTING APPORTIONMENT
PROCESSES TO ALLOCATE THOSE
FUNDS. TO ALL SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE ALLOCATIONS ENABLED A
MULTITUDE OF FOOD SECURITY
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING PROVIDING
CAL FRESHEN WRONG INFORMATION
AND ENROLLMENT SUPPORT TO
STUDENTS.
EXPANDING CAMPUS BASED FOOD
PANTRIES ESTABLISHING HOT MEAL
VOUCHER PROGRAMS DEVELOPING MEAL
DEVOTION DONATION GIVE BACK
PROGRAMS PROVIDING FINANCIAL
LITERACY TRAINING TO STUDENTS
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM.
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE COLLEGES
FOR IMPLEMENTING THE HUNGER FREE
CAMPUS CAMPAIGN WE PARTNERED
WITH OUR CSU PARTNERS AND HOSTED
ELEVEN. REGIONAL TRAININGS THAT
FOCUSED ON THE COW FRESHENED
ROLE IN THE PROCESS OF FACULTY
AND STAFF WOULD BE PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS WITH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
THERE WAS EXTENSIVE INTEREST IN
THESE TROLLS WE HAD EIGHTY TWO
OF THE COLLEGES SEND FACULTY AND
STAFF WE TRAINED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE OVER THE COURSE
OF ABOUT FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS.
SO THERE WAS A VERY HEIGHTENED
INTEREST IN LEARNING ABOUT HOW
TO SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE. FACING FOOD
INSECURITY. PRETTY GRAND UMP
LEVELS.
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS TO HELP COLLEGES CREATE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR LOCAL
FOOD BANKS AND WITH THEIR COUNTY
CAL FRESH STAFF.
CRITICAL TO CREATE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE COUNTY
PARTNERS INCLUDING FOOD BANKS
AND CAL FRESH COUNTY TEAMS AS
THESE RELATIONSHIPS WILL ALLOW
LEVERAGING EXISTING RESOURCES
THAT PROVIDE LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS.
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS TO
CREATE LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE
THE ONE TIME FUNDING ALLOCATION
PROVIDED BY THE STATE ALLOWED
THE COLLEGES TO INVEST. IN FOOD
PANTRY SERVICES CALPERS TRAINING
AND TO DEVELOP THOSE LOCAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
IN TERMS OF HOUSING RESOURCES
THE MAJORITY OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DO NOT OFFER CAMPUS
BASED HOUSING ELEVEN OF OUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN HAVE ON CAMPUS
HOUSING HOWEVER COLLEGES WITHIN
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. ARE WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY BASED HOUSING
PROGRAM CALLED HOVHANESS SOME OF
YOU MAY HAVE OR BE FAMILIAR WITH
HOVHANESS. IT'S AN INITIATIVE
THAT THEY CALL THE COLLEGE
SUCCESS INITIATIVE THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM HOMELESS STUDENTS
RECEIVE HOUSING NAVIGATION
SERVICES RAPID RE HOUSING
SERVICES RENT SUBSIDIES AND
OTHER CASE MANAGEMENT.
THERE ARE A FEW HOUSING BILLS ON
THE SENATE SIDE HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL GARNER SOME SUPPORT SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTEEN AND SENATE
BILL NINE TWELVE. ARE BOTH.
TAP BEING HOUSING DOLLARS. AND
I THINK WE SHOULD TRY TO LOOK TO
TAP HOUSING DOLLARS FOR HOUSING
NEEDS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
I HAVE MORE THINGS BUT.
I WILL OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
AT THIS TIME IF YOU HAVE ANY.
SOUNDS GREAT YES.
IT'S NEXT.
WHO WAS A GREAT LIFT?
I GOOD AFTERNOON CHERUB WEBER
AND MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. I
TO SAY THAT I'M SO PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY WOULD BE A GROSS
UNDERSTATEMENT I AM BEYOND
HONORED TO BE HERE TO REPRESENT%
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
ON THE ISSUE OF BASIC NEEDS
SECURITY FOR STUDENTS IS ONE OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO US AS
EDUCATORS AND ONE THAT HAS BEEN
UNRESOLVED FOR WAY TOO LONG AND
AS YOU ALREADY KNOW.
THAT'S WHY I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE IN
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAVING BECAUSE IT IT IT IT'S
MAKING A DIFFERENCE ALREADY AND
TWEAK. THE SKY'S THE LIMIT IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE COULD POSSIBLY
ACCOMPLISH.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR NANCY GRASS
AND I'M HE ASSOCIATED ASSOCIATE
DEAN OF STUDENT LIFE AT SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE.
AND I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR FOOD
SECURITY PROGRAMS IN A PART OF
THE TEAM OF BASIC NEEDS FOLKS
WHO ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE INTRACTABLE.
INTRACTABLE PROBLEMS THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE FACING TODAY.
THE QUESTION THAT I ALWAYS.
KIND OF PONDER SINCE MY TWENTY
PLUS YEARS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
IS IF STUDENTS DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO SLEEP TONIGHT.
AND WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL IS
COMING FROM HOW CAN THEY
POSSIBLY STUDY FOR CHEMISTRY
EXAM OR WRITE A PAPER.
.
WE'VE KNOWN FOR YEARS
THE RESEARCHERS SHOWN THAT.
ZIP CODE AND INCOME LEVELS ARE A
BETTER PREDICTOR OF STUDENT
SUCCESS
THEN ALL OF THE HER ROBE EFFORTS
THAT WE WE PUT FORWARD FOR THE
MUCH NEEDED LEARNING RESOURCES
WE PROVIDE. BUT IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET IF
THEY'RE TRAVELING THREE HOURS BY
BUS TO GET TO US.
THREE HOURS HOME AND WORKING ALL
NIGHT AND HAVE NO WHERE TO EAT
OR SLEEP.
HOW NO AMOUNT OF EXTRA TUTORING
OR BASIC SKILLS IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY MOVE THAT EQUITY
NEEDLE?
AS A PROFESSOR FOR NINETEEN
YEARS I LEARNED VERY EARLY ON.
I HAD STUDENTS COMING TO CLASS
HUNGRY I HAD SOME THAT WOULD
COME TO CLASS WHO HADN'T SLEPT
BECAUSE THEY JUST SIMPLY HAD
NOWHERE TO SLEEP.
SO I WOULD KEEP LIKE MANY
PROFESSORS WATER BOTTLES PROTEIN
BARS CANDY COOKIES STACKS FRUIT
IN MY OFFICE TO GIVE OUT TO
HUNGRY STUDENTS.
BUT THAT'S SUCH A SMALL
FRACTION.
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN I SUIT MY
CURRENT RULE AS ASSOCIATE DEAN I
GOT THE CHANCE TO WORK WITH THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENT GOVERNMENT
LEADERS. WHO IDENTIFIED FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURITY AS THE MOST
CHALLENGING OBSTACLE THAT THEY
FACE AND TRYING TO GET THEIR
EDUCATION?
AND IT WAS WITH THIS GROUP OF
STUDENTS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DEVELOP OUR FIRST TO FOOD
SECURITY PROGRAMS AT SMC. ARE
FREE LUNCH VOUCHER PROGRAM WE
CALL FLAVOR AND OUR GALLEY FLUTE
FOOD CLOSET PROGRAM.
A YEAR AFTER THAT WE OUT OF A
FREE FARMER'S MARKET AND TODAY
THANKS TO THE HUNGER FREE CAMPUS
ALLOCATION WE ARE BUSILY TRYING
TO EXPAND. ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING A
COMPREHENSIVE CAL FRESH.
OUTREACH PROGRAM.
THE HUNGER FREE ALLOCATION IS
ALSO MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR US
TO DEVISE A PLAN FOR MAKING EACH
OF THESE PROGRAM SELF
SUSTAINING.
A BUT ACTUAL C. IT'S GOING TO
TAKE US SOME TIME TO DO THAT.
OF THE FLAVOR LUNCH PROGRAM
PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED O. TO A.
VOUCHER OR.
PROVIDES VOUCHERS TO TWO HUNDRED
OF OUR MOST NEEDY STUDENTS WE
GIVE THEM FIFTEEN VOUCHERS A
SEMESTER.
THAT GETS THEM ONE HOT MEAL A
WEEK IN THE CAFETERIA.
THE PROGRAM PROGRAM IS COSTING
US ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR CURRENTLY. AND IT HAS
BEEN BY THE GENEROSITY OF ARE
ASSOCIATED STUDENT GOVERNMENTS
THAT THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
FUNDED FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS.
IT IS BUILT ON A STUDENT
SUCCESS MODEL WHICH REQUIRES THE
PARTICIPANTS TO VISIT WITH AN
ACADEMIC COUNSELOR THREE TIMES A
SEMESTER. AND IT ALSO A REQUIRES
THAT THEY MAKE CONSISTENT
ACADEMIC PROGRESS AS LONG AS
THEY'RE ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
AND AGAIN THIS WAS DESIGNED BY
STUDENTS FOR STUDENTS.
I THE GALLEY FOOD CLOSET PROGRAM
IS A DECENTRALIZED FOOD PACKED
PANTRY THE PROVIDES FOOD
DISTRIBUTION CABINETS IN HIGH
NEED AREAS SO WE HAVE ONE IN
ATHLETICS ONE IN OUR BLACK
LEGIONS OF ADELANTE PROGRAM
OFFICE.
ONE IN OUR VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTER ONE ANY.
I THINK IT'S AN ETHIOPIAN ASSN
ALSO A STUDENT LIFE.
STUDENTS CAN ACCESS THESE
BECAUSE IT'S TO PHILIP A BAG OF
GROCERIES TO TAKE HOME AND THEN
THEY ALSO HAVE A SELECTION OF
GRAB AND GO ITEMS SO IF THEY'RE
HUNGRY ON THE SPOT.
IN THE SIXTEEN MONTHS SINCE WE
STARTED THAT PROGRAM THE CLOSETS
ARE PROVIDED OVER TEN THOUSAND
POUNDS OF FOOD.
TO STUDENTS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PURCHASE FOR TWO CENTS A POUND
FROM THE WEST SIDE FOOD BANK.
A GREAT COMMUNITY PARTNER.
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF LEADING A SMALL
GROUP OF FACULTY AND STAFF TO
EXPAND ON A STUDENT INSPIRED BY
ANNUAL FREE FARMER'S MARKET THAT
WAS TIED TOWARDS SUSTAINABILITY
WEEKS.
TODAY THE CORSAIR MARKET
PROVIDES A FIFTEEN HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND POUNDS OF FRESH PRODUCE
EVERY WEDNESDAY TO OVER TWO
HUNDRED HUNGRY MINDS.
AND LET ME TELL YOU TAKES ONE
OUR FIRST TO GO THROUGH THAT
FOOD THE STUDENTS LINE UP AND
WE'VE GOT OUR BEHALF OF
VOLUNTEERS LINED UP AND WE JUST
FILL THEIR GROCERY BAGS AND
TAKES AN HOUR TO GO THROUGH
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. TO TWO THOUSAND
POUNDS OF VEGETABLES AND FRUIT.
AND THOSE STUDENTS ARE SO
GRATEFUL.
ALTHOUGH THE MARKET IT'S ONLY
BEEN RUNNING DURING THE FALL AND
SPRING SEMESTERS WERE DON'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY YET TO DO IT IN THE
INTERCESSIONS.
WE'VE ALREADY DISTRIBUTED OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND POUNDS OF FOOD
WHICH IS ALSO SUPPLIED BY THE
WEST SIDE FOOD BANK AND ALSO
THROUGH THE ORGANIZATION FOOD
FORWARD.
THE MARKET IS RUN BY A TEAM OF
MOSTLY OF VOLUNTEER FACULTY
STAFF AND STUDENTS WHO.
PICK UP THE FOOD FROM THE FOOD
BANK THEY GO TO THE FARMERS
MARKET TO GLEAN THE FOOD THEY
DELIVER IT THEY SET THE ENTIRE
MARKET UP.
THE DISTRIBUTE ALL THE FOOD AND
THEN AFTERWARDS THEY PROCESS ALL
THE DATA
SO THAT WE CAN GET CLEAN NUMBERS
ABOUT WHAT IT IS WE'RE DOING
BECAUSE WE KNEW YOU GUYS WOULD
WANT.
THE HUNGER FREE CAMPUS
ALLOCATION HAS BEEN CRITICAL IN
MOVING ALL THESE PROGRAMS FROM
SMALL STUDENT AND VOLUNTEER
STAFF.
PROJECTS TO INSTITUTIONALIZED
INITIATIVES
BUT IS ALSO ALLOWED US TO HIRE A
TEMPORARY FOOD SECURITY
CONSULTANT WHO'S PROVIDED US
WITH A LOT OF BEST PRACTICES FOR
EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS.
AND SHE'S ALSO BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN HELPING US TO DEVELOP OUR CAL
FRESH OUTREACH AND ENROLLMENT
EFFORTS. BY A PROVIDING CALPERS
TRAINING SHE'S BEEN PARTNERING
WITH LA COUNTY FOR WITH IT FOR
US. AND WE'RE HAVING OUR FIRST
EVER CAL FRESH DAY NEXT WEEK.
WHERE SHE'S ARRANGED TO HAVE
FIVE TO SIX COUNTY FOLKS COME
AND WE'VE GOT APPOINTMENTS SET
UP ALL OVER CAMPUS FOR STUDENTS
TO SIGN UP FOR CONFERENCE ROOM
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT?
WERE MAKING IT WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS SELF
SUSTAINING THROUGH A FUNDRAISING
CAMPAIGN AT SMC CALLED NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE. THAT WAS THE YEAR
THAT SANTA MONICA COLLEGE BEGAN.
AND LIKE THE FOLKS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE OUR STUDENTS ARE
FACING SOME REALLY SERIOUS
CHALLENGES.
SO SIMILAR TO THE CASH REGISTER
DONATIONS THAT WE'VE ALL BECOME
FAMILIAR WITH.
YOU KNOW DONATE TO THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
WE'VE CONVINCED ALL FOR FOR ON
CAMPUS VENDORS TO.
ENCOURAGE CUSTOMERS TO DONATE
TWENTY NINE CENTS A CHECKOUT.
FOR EVERY NINETEEN PEOPLE TO
DONATE TWENTY NINE CENTS THAT
VICE ONE STUDENT A HOT MEAL.
ARE WE ALSO INVITING FACULTY AND
STAFF TO DO PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS
OF NINETEEN DOLLARS AND TWENTY
NINE CENTS.
A MONTH WHICH GIVES US OVER FOR
MORE MEALS.
AND ALSO WORKING WITH OUR
FOUNDATION TO.
GET COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
DONATE AS WELL.
WE ESTIMATE THAT.
WE CAN RAISE ENOUGH ONGOING
MONEY TO MINIMALLY FUND EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS THAT JUST JUST
KIND OF WHAT WORK. PIT WHAT IT'S
COSTING US NOW IS ROUGHLY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ALL OF
THEM.
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE US ABOUT
TWO YEARS TO GET THERE.
IN THE MEANTIME THE HUNGER FREE
FUNDING IS ALL WE HAVE.
IT'S WHAT'S GETTING A STARTED
IS WHAT WE'RE HOPING WILL HELP
KEEP US GOING. AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR ITS MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE FROM TAKING THESE
FROM LITTLE.
INDIVIDUALS WORKING AROUND
CAMPUS TO GET STUFF DONE TO
BEING ABLE TO MAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM.
MY DREAM IS THAT EVERY STUDENT
ENROLLED IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HAS ACCESS TO AT LEAST ONE HOT
MEAL EVERY DAY.
AND AS THEY SAY THAT IS PRETTY
LOW HANGING FRUIT.
WITHOUT THE CURRENT FUNDING OUR
SCHOOLS ARE LEFT TO HOPE THAT A
FEW COMMITTED INDIVIDUALS TAKE
UP THIS WORK AND CARRYING ON.
THAT CARRIED ON UNSUPPORTED AND
UNCOMPENSATED WITHOUT THESE
FUNDS AND CERTAINLY THIS IS NOT
A SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION TO A
PROBLEM THAT WE NOW KNOW IS SO
BIG.
IN CLOSING YOU MIGHT HAVE
NOTICED THAT I ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AS PRUDENT HOUSING
SECURITY. NOT IN SECURITY.
THAT'S BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW WE
HAVE WAY TOO MUCH AND SECURITY
ALREADY WHAT WE NEED. IS A LONG
TERM CONSISTENT AND REAP
RELIABLE BASIC NEED SECURITY
PLAN FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
IF WE DON'T PROVIDE IT FOR THEM
TODAY THEY MAY NOT BE WILLING OR
EVEN ABLE TO PROVIDE IT FOR US
IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
I HUNGER.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON VOUCHER WEBER
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
AND ADVOCATES FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. AND IT IS ALL HODGE
LAMELLAE WITH THE STUDENTS AND
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNE COLLEGE
AND A PROUD SUDAN LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE SITTING TO
HOPEFULLY PURSUE A CAREER IN
CORAL JUSTICE.
I THINK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING TODAY AND GIVING US ALL
HERE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
ISSUES AROUND FOOD AND HOUSING
AND SECURITY THAT IMPACT THE
NUMBER OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND USE THE PHRASE A NUMBER
BECAUSE AT THIS MOMENT AS
COLLEEN MENTIONS WE DO NOT KNOW
HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE AFFECTED
BY THESE ISSUES. BUT WE KNOW
THEY'RE THERE.
EATING IN OUR CLASSROOMS SITTING
IN OUR LIBRARIES AND EVEN
SOMETIMES SLEEPING IN OUR OWN
PARKING LOTS.
I THINK WE SAW UNDERSTAND THE
SENSE HILDA COMES ALONG WITH
TRYING TO IDENTIFY THE STUDENTS.
EVEN AFTER EXPLAINING THAT
SLEEPING ON A DIFFERENT COLLEGE
EVERY WEEK OR NOT HAVING ENOUGH
MONEY T. BREAKFAST WHERE THEY
CAN BE A.
A DEGREE OF INSECURITY SOME
STUDENTS WILL CONTINUE TO DENY
BECAUSE THE SIGMA ASSOCIATED WE
HEAR THE WORDS HOMELESS OR EVEN
IN SECURE.
AND KNOW CITY WANTS TO BE
STATISTICALLY TO BE CATEGORIZED
AS SOMEONE WHO NEEDS EXTRA HELP.
SO THE QUICK ACTIVITY I HAD
THOUGHT I HAD A LITTLE MORE TIME
BUT I WANT US ALL TO HEAR TO
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND THAT WOULD
HOMELESS ARE FOOD INSECURE
STUDENT LOOKS LIKE.
HOW DOES YOUR HAIR LOOK LIKE?
WHAT KIND OF CLOTHES ARE THEY
WEARING BUT THEY CAN'T ANY ITEMS
WITH THEM?
LOOK AROUND THE ROOM DO WE THINK
ANYONE HERE TODAY FACE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE STUDENTS
CAN LOOK LIKE ANYONE OF US HERE
TODAY AND TO PROBABLY ADDRESSES
ISSUES WE HAVE TO GET RID OF ANY
PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS WE HAVE
ABOUT THESE POPULATIONS.
IT'S SOMETIMES DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE THAT ALTHOUGH CD MAYBE
WORKING IT'S STILL POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO FACE SOME DEGREE OF FOOD
AND HOUSING AND SECURITY. WE
TELL STUDENTS THAT THEY MUST
WORK TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE HOURS
A WEEK TO MEET THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN OF ATTENDING COLLEGE WE
HAVE TO IMAGINE THE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS OF THE STUDENTS ARE
ENTERING.
MOST STUDENTS HAVE INTERACTED
WITH LIKE MYSELF WORK PART TIME
JOBS AT RETAIL LOCATIONS MOVIE
THEATERS ARE IN SOME FORM OF
FAST FOOD SERVICE. YOU KNOW JUST
THIS MONTH A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
TO STRUGGLING TO FIND AN EXTRA
SOURCE OF INCOME.
BUT TO HELP PAY FOR RENT BECAUSE
HOURS WERE CUT THE TEN HOURS A
WEEK SIMPLY DUE TO SOMETHING OUT
OF HIS CONTROL LIKE LET SHOPPERS
IN A PARKING.
SO ANY LEVEL FOOD HOUSING OF
SECURITY CAN BE A DETERMINING
FACTOR WHETHER SOMEONE DECIDES
TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION AND
EVEN I AS YES PASSED AS THEY
HAVE ABOUT THE PURSUIT OF
LEARNING. WOULD NOT HESITATE TO
CHOOSES THE SURVIVAL MYSELF MY
FAMILY OVER MY PROCEED EDUCATION
AND THESE ARE NOT DECISIONS THAT
I THOUGHT STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
TO MAKING.
AS AN ORGANIZATION WE HAVE DONE
OUR BEST TO HELP EASE THE CITY
LIFE EXPERIENCE. IN JUST TWO
YEARS AGO THERE WAS AN ASSEMBLY
BILL THAT EXPANDED SHOWER
FACILITIES TO HOMELESS YOU KNOW
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES. NOW I'M
STILL AMAZED BY THE STUDENTS WHO
TOOK EXTRA EFFORTS IN WHO ARE
COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO SHARE THEIR
PERSONAL STORIES.
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID
NOT COMMEND THOSE COLLEGES. WHO
DID NOT LIMITED TO JUST HOMELESS
STUDENTS BUT EXPANDED TO ALL
THEIR SERVICES ALL THEIR
STUDENTS IN GENERAL?
SO HAVE YOU HERE HAVE AUTHORED
LEGISLATION TACKLE THESE ISSUES
AND WE DEFTLY THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE AS
WELL.
NEED SOME COLLEGES ARE ALSO
DOING SOME GREAT WORK TO COMBAT
THESE ISSUES LIKE CREATING FOOD
PANTRIES AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
ALLOWING THE DISBURSEMENT OF
EMERGENCY GRANTS AND DEVELOPING
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS.
TO EXPAND SERVICES OUTSIDE THE
ROUTINE COLLEGE CAMPUS HOURS.
WE HEAR STORIES OF AMAZING FOOD
PANTRIES WHERE STUDENTS AND EVEN
THEIR FAMILIES CAN COME IN AND
TAKE POUNDS OF FRESH FRUIT
THAT'S OFFERED TO THEM AT NO
COST.
SIMILAR STORIES ARE SHARED ABOUT
HOW STUDENTS FACE THEN EMERGENCY
WAS ABLE TO ACCESS ADDITIONAL
FUNDS QUICK ENOUGH TO RESPOND TO
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS AND
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION. AND IT
SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE TO ANYONE
HERE THAT THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE TO STUDENTS ARE LIMITED
ESPECIALLY AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND SOME OF THE INNOVATIVE WAYS
COLLEGES ARE DRESSING THESE
ISSUES IS A PARTING WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
STUDENTS CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS OUTSIDE OF THEIR SPECIFIC
INSTITUTIONS.
COLLEGES A PARTING WITH LOCAL
FOOD BANKS TO STUDENTS CAN SHOP
ON WEEKENDS A LOCAL CHURCHES TO
OFFER ADDITIONAL SHOCK
FACILITIES AND SOMETIMES EVEN
WITH SELF WITH THE STUDENTS CAN
HAVE OPTIONS TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS.
YOU DON'T EVEN OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WE'RE HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS
AS KALI MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAD
OUR FIRST EVER BASIC NEEDS
SUMMIT JUST HERE LAST WEEK. AND
WERE EXCITED TO SEE WHERE THAT
GOES ON MOVING FORWARD.
BUT THERE IS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
YOU KNOW JUST DUE TO THE RECENCY
OF SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS.
A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE
SEEN OUR SOMETIMES REACTIONARY.
YOU KNOW SOME THESE INSTITUTIONS
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
RESOURCES LIKE TWO HUNDRED MEAL
VOUCHERS AVAILABLE TO THEIR
ENTIRE STUDENT POPULATION OF
SOMETIMES TWENTY TO THIRTY
THOUSAND.
AND SOMETIMES SOME COLLEGES HAVE
TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES THAT
STUDENTS HALF OF YOUR EFFORTS BY
FACULTY MEMBER STAFF MEMBER
STEVEN ACCESS THE SERVICES. AND
ALTHOUGH WELL INTENTIONED THESE
ARE NOT MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS WHO. ONE DON'T SELF
IDENTIFY OR TWO DON'T EVEN KNOW
THE FACE THESE INSECURITIES FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO
IMAGINE HOW HEARTBREAKING I MUST
BE FOR FACULTY OR STAFF MEMBERS
HAVE TO TURN AWAY STUDENT SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE SERVICE IS NO LONGER
AVAILABLE.
WE COULD BE MORE PRODUCTIVE IN
OUR APPROACH IF WE KNEW BUT MORE
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS.
I TALK ABOUT THIS SOME EARLIER
WHERE IN THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
SYSTEM WE UNDERSTAND OUT IN.
THAT STUDENTS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR FREE OR REDUCED LUNCH
PROGRAM WE UNDERSTAND THERE IS A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE FOR THAT STUDENT. AND
WOULD A STUDENT LEAVES THAT
INSTITUTION THE NEEDS OUT
DISAPPEAR IT FOLLOWS THEM
THROUGHOUT THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOINING IF WE HAD SOME WAYS TO
COLLECT THAT INFORMATION ENTER
INTO THE REACHING AGREEMENTS WE
COULD DO MORE TO MEET THEIR
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE.
LOCALLY WE MUST ALSO COMMUNICATE
AVAILABILITY OF THE SERVICES TO
STUDENTS AT EVERY POINT OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY.
YOU KNOW WE CANNOT PREDICT THE
FUTURE AT LEAST I KNOW I CAN'T
WE CAN AT LEAST PREPARE FOR
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS. WE COULD BE
SHARING INFORMATION ORIENTATIONS
AND CYCLOPS ROOMS USING STILL BY
OFFERING WORKSHOPS THROUGHOUT
THE SEMESTER AND HOSTING EVENTS
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE CRAMMING
DURING FINALS.
AND OVERALL I OPTIMISTICALLY
BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM IS DEDICATED TO ENSURING
THAT ALL OUR STUDENTS ARE
SUCCESSFUL. AND REGARDLESS OF
WHAT STUDENT SUCCESS MEANS TO
YOU ARE US.
WE MUST NOT FORGET THAT SOME
STUDENTS CANNOT REALIZE A DREAM
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT KNOW WHERE
THEY WILL SLEEP TONIGHT OR
WHETHER NEXT MEAL WILL BE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MISTER.
WITH MEDINA THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER.
I'VE I BELIEVE WAS YESTERDAY
DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY.
WE HEARD.
DIFFERENT.
SUGGESTIONS AS YOU MENTION.
MORE INFORMATION
SHARED WITH STUDENTS AT EARLIER
TIME PERHAPS A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AS YOU KNOW AS EARLY AS
HIGH SCHOOL. ON THE DIFFICULTY
OF THE MANEUVERING THROUGH. A
THE NEEDS THAT THEY'RE GONNA
FACE AS COLLEGE STUDENTS I THINK
IN IN ALL THREE SYSTEMS.
AND.
AND THE AND I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
SYSTEMS THAT THREE SYSTEMS AND
THE STUDENTS IN THOSE SYSTEMS.
GREAT THANK THEIR VERY
INNOVATIVE.
AND THOUGHTFUL WAYS THAT THEY
HAVE COME UP THEMSELVES.
TO TACKLE THE THE VERY.
.
SERIOUS ISSUES OF BOTH HOME AND
FOOD INSECURITY. AND THEY ARE TO
BE COMMENDED.
FOR ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN.
AND THEY CERTAINLY ARE
INNOVATIVE.
BUT MY QUESTION TO YOU OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS WHAT.
CAN THE STATE DO.
AND THE WHAT WHAT WHAT
SUGGESTIONS DO YOU HAVE TO US.
AS STATE LEGISLATORS
TO TO.
.
YOU KNOW TO FACE.
THEY HISH ISSUE HEAD ON INTO.
HOW? THE THREE SYSTEMS WITH THE
WITH WITH THE ISSUE BECAUSE I I
THINK IT SOUNDS LIKE TO ME. THAT
THE SCHOOLS OF KIND OF BEEN THE
SCHOOLS IN THE STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN. KIND OF.
LEFT ALONE TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES.
SO MY QUESTION TO THE THREE OF
YOU IS WHAT. SUGGESTIONS DO YOU
HAVE FOR US.
HOW CAN WE BETTER HELP THE
STUDENTS?
?
WITH THE ISSUES
YOU KNOW THE FIRST THING THAT
COMES TO MIND IS IS ANY EFFORTS
THAT CAN BE DONE TO STREAMLINE
THE CAL FRESH APPLICATION
PROCESS.
AND.
ENCOURAGING.
COUNTY ACCOUNT FOR STAFF TO YOU
KNOW PARTICIPATE AS ROBUSTLY AND
THEY ARE PARTICIPATING QUITE
ROBUSTLY IN IN PARTICULAR PLACES
IN THE STATE BUT. I THINK ANY
ENCOURAGEMENT OR ANY LEGISLATION
THAT THAT SORT OF PUSHES TOWARD
THAT.
I'D DO STILL THINK THAT WE HAVE
SOME ISSUES AROUND.
COLLEGES ACCESSING LOCAL FOOD
BANK RESOURCES BECAUSE OF THIS
NONPROFIT ISSUE AND I THINK WE
HAVE SOMEONE IN THE ROOM WHO.
RACHEL FROM SWIPE WHO'S OFFERED
TO HELP US
TRIED TO GET SOME RESOLUTION ON
THAT BUT YOU CAN TAKE UP TO TWO
TWO YEARS TO GET THOSE
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE IN SOME
PLACES. BECAUSE OF THAT
NONPROFIT ISSUE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO LOOK AT THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND TO TRY TO DELVE INTO
THAT BECAUSE I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY. THAT'S WHERE
STUDENTS ARE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS BECAUSE IT'S JUST SO
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. OF THE FOR NON STOOD
FOR AND ALL OF US RIGHT AND SO
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
STUDENTS.
BUNKING UP EIGHT IN A IN A ONE
OR TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT I THINK
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO AROUND
HOUSING IS WOULD BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL TO THE STUDENTS.
THE MOST OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DON'T HAVE HOUSING YEAH
ELEVEN OF THE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN HAVE LIMITED.
DORMITORY OR OR CAMPUS BASED
HOUSING.
ANYONE ELSE YEAH.
AT THE SUMMIT THE BASIC NEED
SOME OF THAT WE ALL ATTENDED
LAST WEEK.
SOMEONE DISCUSS THE IDEA THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE CASE
THROUGH TWELVE.
FREE OR REDUCED LUNCH OR FREE
BREAKFAST PROGRAMS AND AT THE
MOMENT THEY TURN EIGHTEEN AND
MOVE ON TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THEY'RE CUT OFF FROM THAT. AND
THERE ISN'T A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE TWO SYSTEMS
TWO ONE HELP US IDENTIFY WHO
MIGHT BE HIGH RISK.
AND HAVING SOME WAY IN WHICH
THAT WE CAN WOULD KNOW WHO THOSE
STUDENTS ARE BECAUSE LIKE YOU
KNOW BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE
STIGMA AROUND IT AND. AND THEIR
NEW TO COLLEGE IN THE DON'T KNOW
HOW THE SYSTEMS WORKS AND THEY
HAVE A HARD TIME FINDING
RESOURCES ANYWAY.
JUST BEING ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
AMONG THE SYSTEMS IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AND. EXTENDING SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS INTO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AYE I THINK
WOULD BE AN AMAZING STEP
FORWARD.
IT CERTAINLY WOULD ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF HAVING THEM AT LEAST BE
FED ONCE A DAY.
ON I HAD A STUDENT WHO CAME TO
ME YESTERDAY WHO WAS ONE OF OUR
STUDENT LEADERS A YEAR AGO. WHO
KEPT TELLING HIM HE DID LOOK
OKAY AND I KEPT ASKING HIM IT
WAS SUPER EMBARRASSED BY THE
SOLEMN COUCH SURFING I'M FINE?
THIRD TIME THIS SEMESTER I SAW
HIM WITH HIS SUITCASE AND HE'D
LOST LIKE TWENTY POUNDS HE STUCK
SKIN AND BONES. AND UNLIKE OUR
AGAIN IN MY OFFICE WHAT IS GOING
ON IS A POINT IN ONE ANYBODY TO
KNOW.
I WAS LIKE OKAY I CAN'T HELP YOU
IF YOU DON'T TELL ME AND WE WERE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW AS A AS A
HUNTER MENTIONS THERE'S YOU KNOW
WE. CONNECTING TO AN EMERGENCY
LOAN WE CONNECT HIM TO THE
FLAVOR PROGRAM TO GET HIM SOME
FOOD VOUCHERS WE GET HIM SOME
FOOD OUT OF THE CLOSET. BUT
THAT'S NOT GONNA HOPE LONG TERM
WE NEED WE NEED SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL HELP US GET THERE.
IT YOU KNOW HOUSING SOLUTIONS
RIGHT YOU BEING IN SANTA MONICA
YOU KNOW HEAR TONS OF STORIES OF
STUDENTS WHO WERE LIVING IN ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENTS WITH EIGHT OR
TWELVE PEOPLE. AND THEY TAKE
SHIFTS SLEEPING.
IT'S
WERE IN A REALLY UNSUSTAINABLE.
CONTEXT RIGHT NOW NATIONWIDE BUT
PARTICULARLY THINK CALIFORNIA
AND AND ENDS.
IS IT IS REALLY SUFFERING.
AND AND I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT
WE'RE NOW TALKING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I THINK THIS PROBLEMS
BUT HER A LOT LONGER THAN.
ANYONE WAS GIVING IT AIR.
SO.
YEAH
IF I SUGGESTIONS. YEAH AT LIKE
TO JUST
TOUCH UPON A LITTLE BIT OF THE
COMMENTS ARE MADE EARLIER. YES
SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE
OUTLINES. YOU KNOW THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS A HUGE IMPACT FOR IN
ALL VERSIONS ACROSS OUR SEGMENTS
IN WITH ME. WHEN WE SPEAK TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE TOO
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT A
COMMUNICATIVE IN IS THERE.
YOU KNOW HOW TO MANEUVER THROUGH
THE SYSTEM YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
THINK THEY LIVE AT HOME RIGHT
LIVE WITH THEIR PARENTS.
.
SOME OF THE ONLY ONES THAT WHEN
WE PARTNER WITH THIS USE USER
UC'S TO OFFER YOU KNOW HOUSING I
TOLD THEM YOU KNOW WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
ALREADY IMPACTED BY THEIR
INSTITUTIONS ITSELF.
SO HOUSING CRISIS IS A HUGE ONE
THAT IMPACTS LOT OF STUDENTS.
KNOW TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AND
STUDENTS LIVING IN THEIR CARS
ABOUT IF WE HAVE NO MEANINGFUL.
YOU KNOW IMPACT IF YOU HAVE NO
MEANINGFUL LEGISLATION TOWARDS
AT WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO FOR OUR
STUDENTS BESIDES TELLING HIM TO
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AND THEN EXPANDING YOU KNOW CAL
FRESH AYE ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT
EXPANDING YOU KNOW ANYTHING TO
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO BOTH APPLY
INSTITUTIONS TO. TO RECOMMEND
THOSE APPLICATIONS CAN DO A LOT.
IT THERE'S THERE'S LESS OF A
CIGAR AROUND YOU KNOW THAT THE
IDEA OF OF CAL FRESH RAIN IN THE
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT I'VE SEEN.
OF STUDENTS ARE MORE COURAGE NOW
ESPECIALLY MY COLLEGE TO APPLY
AND TO UTILIZE THOSE SERVICES
THAT'S A HUGE STEP FORWARD WHO
CAN DEFTLY TAKE SOME MORE STEPS
TO. IMPROVE IN THAT ACCESS TO A
LOT OF OUR STUDENTS.
DOUBLE DUTCH IS NOT SHARED WITH
INSTITUTIONS ARE OUR SYSTEMS
ABOUT SOME STUDENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY HIGH RISK INDICATORS
TELL SYSTEM. SO WE HAD AWAY AS A
CALLING MENTION TO IDENTIFY
THOSE STUDENTS A LITTLE EARLIER
AND FIND THOSE POTENTIAL HIGH
RISK STUDENTS WE CAN ADJUST THEM
SPECIFICALLY.
AS ONE OF THE ISSUES WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS IS COMMUNICATING TO
STUDENTS ABOUT THE SERVICES. AND
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO RIGHT NOW IS
CASTING A WIDE NET BECAUSE WE DO
NOT KNOW WHO THE STUDENTS ARE.
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES WE CAN
ONLY DO SO MUCH TALKING US THIS
AND AND THEY'RE AN AREA OR
POPULATION CAN DO A LOT MORE
GOOD.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD HEAR FROM THE NEXT PANEL
LEE MAYBES ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FOR YOU LATER ON BUT LAW TO MAKE
SURE WE GET TO THE SECOND PANEL
WHICH DEALS WITH THE C. ISSUE
SYSTEM.
AND.
WE HAVE THREE INDIVIDUALS HERE
DOCTOR BEV DID NIECE BEVERLY WAS
A DIRECTIVE STUDENT WELLNESS AND
BASIC NEEDS.
AND WE HAVE THE OXYGEN MCGUIRE
WHOSE. FESTIVE HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY AND MAGGIE Y. WHO IS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
OKAY.
THANKS.
PEOPLE LIKE WE DON'T HAVE TO.
OR ANYTHING.
OKAY.
SO ONE OF THE POWER POINT WE DO.
OKAY NOW IT'S UP TO YOU.
THIS STEP IS HERE.
THERE WAS NO REDUCTIVE BEVERLY.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT CHEN MY NAME IS DENISE
BEVERLY I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
STUDENT WELLNESS AND BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVE. AT THE CSU TO START
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE.
AND YOU LEGISLATIVE CA HOW
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
OUR EFFORTS TO HELP ME. BASIC
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS THE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED BY THE BUDGET ACT.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I TO THE CSU
HAS BEEN DISPERSED ALL TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES.
TO HELP THEM BECOME DESIGNATED
AS HUNGER FREE.
WE USED A RFP PROCESS IN WHICH
CAMPUSES COULD APPLY FOR DOLLARS
IN THREE DIFFERENT AREAS. BEING
REQUIRED ACTIVITIES ENCOURAGED
ACTIVITIES AND INNOVATIVE
ACTIVITIES SO THESE FUNDS WILL
BE CRITICAL IN HELPING OUR
CAMPUSES DEVELOP IMPLEMENT. AND
ENHANCE RESOURCES TO FOOD
INSECURITY IN HOUSING
DISPLACEMENT.
THANK YOU.
OUR COMMITMENT TO CSU STUDENTS
ENTER ACADEMIC IN FUTURE SUCCESS
NECESSITATES A COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING THEIR BASIC NEEDS
WINSTON'S BASIC NEEDS ARE NOT A
DRASTIC IMPACT BOTH THEIR
PERSONAL AND ACADEMIC GROWTH.
IMPEDING THEIR ABILITY TO TO TO
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS AND EARNED A
DEGREE. THAT IS WHITE STUDENT
WELL BEING AS A PRIORITY ON OUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THIS YES USE PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
POSITIVELY IMPACTING THEIR
FUTURE AND PRODUCING ADDITIONAL
GRADUATES TO POWER CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND INNOVATION.
FIFTY S. USE BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVE IS A SYSTEM WIDE
EFFORT TO COORDINATE SERVICES
AROUND CAMPUS IS HELPING THEM
REACH ALL STUDENTS IN NEED OF
SUPPORT. THEN MISSION OF THE
STRUCTURE AROUND FIVE KEY AREAS
ADDRESSING THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS GROWING CAMPUS
SPACE.
BASIC NEEDS SERVICES SO THEY CAN
REACH ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
SCALING BEST PRACTICES FROM ONE
CAMPUS TO ACROSS THE SYSTEM
WORKING WITH PARTNERS LOCALLY
STATEWIDE IN FEDERALLY. AND
ENSURING LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF BASIC NEEDS
SERVICE SAYS.
THE CSU CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN HARD
AT WORK LINKING STUDENTS TO
THAT ADDRESS FOOD INSECURITY
HOUSING DISPLACEMENT. AND
HOMELESSNESS.
SO TO START OFF WITH A DRESSING.
FOOD INSECURITY MANY OF OUR
CAMPUSES HAVE ALL TWENTY THREE
OF OUR CAMPUSES EITHER OT SOME
SORT OF FOOD DISTRIBUTION OUR
FOOD PANTRY PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HAVE OUR CAMPUSES THAT
ARE DOING CALTRANS APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS MEALS
SHARING OF VOUCHERS PROGRAMS IN
WHICH STUDENTS CAN DONATE TO
OTHER STUDENTS.
SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES ALSO HAVE
GARDEN PROGRAMS IN WHICH
STUDENTS ARE TAUGHT HOW TO.
GROW THEIR OWN FOOD WE ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH CAMPUS IS TO GET AB
T. ON CAMPUS.
AND THEN ALSO NOTIFICATION
SEVERAL OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE AN
APP THAT WAS DEVELOPED TO LET
STUDENTS KNOW WHEN THERE IS LEFT
OVER FOOD FROM AN EVENT. OUR ON
CAMPUS SO THAT HAD THEY HAD
ACCESS TO A MEAL.
CSU CAMPUSES ARE ALSO PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH SHORT TERM
EMERGENCY HOUSING MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF OUR CAMPUSES OFFER ON
CAMPUS EMERGENCY HOUSING OR
VOUCHERS FOR OFF CAMPUS HOUSING.
FOR EXAMPLE AT CSU CHICO STAFF
PROVIDE STUDENTS FACING I'M.
FACING HOMELESSNESS AND A
HOUSING EMERGENCY VOUCHER HOTEL
VOUCHER TO PROVIDE SHORT TERM
RELIEF AND THE CAMPUS WILL SERVE
AS A CO SIGNER ON LEASE
AGREEMENTS TO HELP STUDENTS
TRANSITION INTO LONG TERM
HOUSING.
SIMILARLY CSU NORTHRIDGE WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR SECURITY
DEPOSITS TO HELP STUDENTS GROW.
IN NEED TO PROCURE HOUSING.
SEE IF YOU CANVASES ALSO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS
IN NEED MORE THAN EIGHTY PERCENT
OF OUR CSU STUDENTS RECEIVE SOME
FORM OF NON LOAN AID. BUT BEYOND
FEDERAL STATE AND INSTITUTIONAL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS THE
MAJORITY OF OUR CAMPUSES ALSO
OFFER EMERGENCY GRANTS OR FUNDS.
FOR EXAMPLE SAN JOSE STATE
OFFERS EMERGENCY GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS.
THAT THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
REPAY SANTA SACRAMENTO STATE
ALSO OFFERS EMERGENCY GRANTS AND
HOST FINANCIAL LITERACY
WORKSHOPS TO TEACH STUDENTS
ABOUT MONEY MANAGEMENT AND
BUDGETING.
WE ARE PROUD OF THE VISION OUR
CAMPUSES HAVE TAKEN TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS HAD ON AND
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEIR
EFFORTS FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE ALSO KNOW THERE IS
MUCH MORE TO BE DONE. AND LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LEGISLATIVE
ALLIES TO HELP TO HELP US ENSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
TEN.
YEAH.
AND I'M NOT SURE.
AT THE BOTTOM LINE
.
RIGHT THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER AND TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CAMPUS CLIMATE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE. ABOUT
A BASIC NEEDS RESEARCH IN THE
CSU AND PROGRAMMING AT MY HOME
CAMPUS HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY.
AND DOCTOR CHEN REQUIREMENTS
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF SOCIAL
WORK AT HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND COKIE I FOR THE
CSU STUDY OF STUDENT BASIC.
DOCTOR RASHEEDA CRUTCHFIELD
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF SOCIAL
WORK AT LONG BEACH STATE.
FIRST ON THE TALK ABOUT THE
STUDY AND THEN I'LL TALK ABOUT
EACH ISSUE PROGRAMMING. THE
STUDY WAS COMMISSIONED BY CSU
CHANCELLOR TIMOTHY WHITE AND IS
PART OF THE CSU BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVE.
THIS IS THE SECOND PHASE OF A
THREE PART STUDY FINDINGS WERE
RELEASED IN FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR.
FACE TO WITH THE SYSTEM WIDE
MIXED METHOD STUDY THAT DESCRIBE
THE PREVALENCE HEALTH FACTORS
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND
EXPERIENCES OF CSU STUDENT WITH
HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSECURITY.
OVER TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS ON ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES COMPLETED SURVEYS AND
TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN STUDENTS ON
ELEVEN CAMPUSES. PARTICIPATED IN
INTERVIEWS AND FOCUS GROUPS AND
FALL TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IN
SPRING TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
DOCTOR CRUTCHFIELD ARE CURRENTLY
COLLECTING DATA ON FEES THREE
WHICH WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ABOUT BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES TAKING
PLACE IN THE CSU. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THIS REPORT TO BE
RELEASED.
IN EARLY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
GROUPS.
THERE WE GO.
OKAY. IN THE CSU WE FOUND THAT
FORTY ONE POINT SIX PERCENT OF
STUDENTS EXPERIENCED FOOD
INSECURITY IN THE LAST THIRTY
DAYS.
TIFFANY FROM LONG BEACH THE
SHARED ABOUT WHAT'S VERY LOW
FOOD SECURITY WAS LIKE FOR HER.
SHE SAID SO BASICALLY WHAT I
USED TO DO WITH THE THREE DAYS
OUT OF THE WEEK IT WAS LIKE
MINUTE MAID AND SHIPS AND
ALBEIT.
I WOULD NEED ANYTHING ELSE
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY
MONEY.
SHE DID THIS IN HIGH SCHOOL ALSO
BUT BACK THEN SHE HAD QUALIFIED
FOR FREE LUNCH THESE ISSUES
DON'T JUST STOP WHEN YOU
GRADUATEFROM HIGH SCHOOL.
TIFFANY WAS NOT AN HOUR LATER
AND WE HEARD THIS TYPE OF STORY
MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT OUR
RESEARCH.
IN THE STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT
NEARLY ELEVEN PERCENT OF CSU
STUDENTS REPORTED BEING HOMELESS
IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS ONE
ON.
ONE OR MORE TIMES.
WELL IS A BIT FROM FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY SHARED ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCE WITH HOMELESSNESS.
AND SO ENDED UP BEING HOMELESS
FOR ABOUT FOUR MONTHS SLEEPING
ON FRIENDS COUCHES AND STAYING
IN MY CAR.
ELIZABETH HAD BUDGETED JUST FINE
FOR THE YEAR BUT SHE WAS EVICTED
TO GET COMPETITIVE COMPETITIVELY
HIGHER RENTAL RATES SHOULD IN
BUDGET FOR A NEW DEPOSIT. AND
THE FIRST AND LAST MONTH'S RENT
AND SHE ENDED UP HAVING TO LEAVE
SCHOOL.
RELATED TO ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
WE FOUND THAT THE MORE FOOD
INSECURE OR HIGHER THE INCIDENCE
OF HOMELESSNESS A STUDENT
EXPERIENCE THE LOWER THE
REPORTED GPA. AND THE HIGHER THE
LEVEL OF ACADEMIC CONCERNS.
SUCH AS WORRY ABOUT GRADES AND
TEST TAKING TROUBLE
CONCENTRATING TIME MANAGEMENT
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
FOR THE HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
INDICATORS WE FOUND THE MORE
FOOD INSECURE AND THE MORE. A
STUDENT WAS HOMELESS THE MORE
SYMPTOMS OF POOR MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH EXPRIENCE THE
LAST THIRTY DAYS. AND THE MORE
DAYS MISSED OF SCHOOL OR WORK.
STUDENTS MISS NEARLY DOUBLE
DOUBLE OR NEARLY DOUBLE THE DAYS
WHEN COMPARED WITH THEIR PEERS
WHOSE BASIC NEEDS ARE BEING MET.
WE HEARD A LOT OF PUSH BACK
ABOUT HOW STUDENTS FACE FOOD
INSECURITY IN HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE SO WE ASK STUDENTS
ABOUT WHY THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
BUY GROCERIES. WE ASKED ABOUT
SPENDING HABITS SUCH AS BUYING
ALCOHOL EATING OUT GOING OUT
WITH FRIENDS AS WELL AS
QUESTIONS ABOUT BUDGETING AND
CONFUSION WITH PAYING BILLS.
I KNOW SOME STUDENTS DID
STRUGGLE WITH BUDGETING ISSUES
NEARLY TWENTY PERCENT
OVERWHELMINGLY WE FOUND THAT
MOST STUDENTS OVER SEVENTY
PERCENT DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO BUY GROCERIES BECAUSE
THEY SIMPLY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY. AND THIS MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE ON AVERAGE WE KNOW THAT
A PUBLIC FOUR YEAR DEGREE COST
TWELVE THOUSAND MORE DOLLARS PER
YEAR. IN WHAT IS PROVIDED IN A
FULL FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE
INCLUDING LOANS.
WHEN THERE IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY
OFTEN BASIC NEEDS ARE THE FIRST
TO GO.
SO CAL FRESHMAN CAMPUS EMERGENCY
FOR FOOD PANTRY INCREASE FOOD
PANTRY USE INCREASE WHEN
STUDENTS REPORTED LOAN VERY LOW.
FOOD INSECURITY HOWEVER
UTILIZATION IS WERE STILL VERY
LOW AT THE TIME A DATA
COLLECTION. AND WE EVEN THOUGH
WE KNOW THAT HOW FRESH THE
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT WHICH IS
CLEAR IN THE DATA AND ALSO IN
THE WORDS OF STUDENT FIONA WHO
SHARED HOW MUCH IT REALLY
MATTERS. SHE SAID I DON'T
REMEMBER HOW MUCH I GOT THIS
MONTH BUT THAT WAS THE ONLY
SEMESTER IN COLLEGE OF EVER MADE
THE DEAN'S LIST. I WAS GETTING
HEALTHY FOOD AND I THINK ABOUT
MONEY PROBLEMS OBVIOUSLY
CONSUMES YOU.
IF I WAS GETTING ENOUGH
NUTRITION I WAS GETTING ENERGY I
WAS AWAKEN EATEN BREAKFAST EVERY
MORNING CAO FRESH MADE A
DIFFERENCE.
SO RESPONDING TO STUDENTS WHO
ARE HOUSING IN FOOD INSECURE
WILL REQUIRE COMPLEX AND LONG
TERM APPROACHES APPROACHES IN
SOLUTION BUILDING. HOPE YOU TAKE
TIME TO REVIEW THE PROGRAM
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE EXECUTIVE
SUMMARY.
NOW I'M GOING TO SWITCH GEARS
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT WE ARE DOING
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS HUMBOLDT
STATE UNIVERSITY.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
WE STARTED WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING FOOD SECURITY WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A STEP O.
SNATCHED IN FOOD PROGRAMS
EMERGENCY FOOD INITIATIVES WITH
AN EYE ON FOOD RECOVERING
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY.
HOWEVER MANY STUDENTS SHOWED UP
THE TIME THAT THAT WAS NOT THEIR
ONLY BE SICK NEED. THEY'RE ALL
THAT THEY WERE STRUGGLING TO ME.
HUMBOLDT COUNTY IS IN A HOUSING
CRISIS AND OUR STUDENTS ARE
BEING HIT HARD NINETEEN PERCENT
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
THE LAST YEAR. BOTTOM LINE IS WE
HAVE A MAJOR HOUSING SHORTAGE IN
OUR AREA WHICH KEEPS RENT PRICES
HIGH. STUDENTS WITH ANY
DISADVANTAGES ARE PUSHED OUT OF
THE MARKET.
ONE OF OUR NEWEST AND MOST
INNOVATIVE INITIATIVES AS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH AREA ONE AGENCY
ON AGING CALLED THE NEST A HOME
SHARING LIVING ARRANGEMENT. THIS
IS WHERE A THIRD PARTY OFFER
SUPPORT TO RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS BY WAY OF MATCHING.
IT PROVIDE INFORMATIONAL
BOOKLETS MEETINGS WORKSHOPS AND
REFERRALS TO SERVICES THIS IS
WHERE STUDENTS CAN DO WORK IN
EXCHANGE FOR CHEAPER RENT
CREATING AFFORDABLE LIVING
OPTIONS FOR BOTH SENIORS AND
STUDENTS.
ANOTHER PROGRAM WATCH THIS YEAR
TRAIN STAFF AND FACULTY AS WELL
BEING AMBASSADORS. TO LEARN
ABOUT RESOURCES THAT CAN GUIDE
STUDENTS MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH CRISES
WHICH WE KNOW ARE MUCH MORE
PREVALENT AMONG STUDENTS WHO ARE
FOOD AND HOUSING AND SECURE.
MORE THAN HALF OUR STUDENTS COME
TO EACH ISSUE WITHOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE AND.
SURE IS A COLLECTION OF
SERVICES THAT HELPS EACH ISSUE
STUDENTS NAVIGATE THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND SIGN UP FOR
INSURANCE INCLUDING MEDI CAL.
AND THE PEER EDUCATORS THAT WORK
IN THE FOOD PANTRY ARE HELPING
TO. IMPLEMENT ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH MANY
PARTNERS TO HELP STUDENTS MEET
THEIR IMMEDIATE BASIC NEEDS
CONTINUED FUNDING OF THE
CALIFORNIA HUNGER FREE CAMPUS
BILL HELPS US DO THAT. AGES YOU
FUNDS FROM THE BILL ARE
SUPPORTING FOOD AN INFASTRUCTURE
FOR OH SNAP AND THE LAUNCH OF A
THRIFT STORE AND FURNITURE SLOP.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM
OF RESOURCES MANY STUDENTS
NEARLY HALF CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY
FOR COLLEGE DEGREE AND LIVING
EXPENSES ON THEIR CURRENT
BUDGETS. AND GENERAL THESE ARE
NOT PROBLEMS THAT OCCUR FROM
POOR DECISION MAKING THESE ARE
PROBLEMS OF A BROKEN SYSTEM AND
WE NEED POLICY SOLUTIONS. THAT
AIM TO IDENTIFY AN INCREASE
STUDENT ASSETS
SUCH AS PELL AND WORK STUDY AND
FIND WAYS TO OFFER HEALTHY FOOD
AND SAFE HOUSING THAT IS
AFFORDABLE FOR ALL STUDENTS.
THAT IS WHY WE'RE COMING TO YOU
HIGHER EDUCATION OF THE SYSTEM
NEEDS TO MOVE BEYOND PATCHING
THE PROBLEM AND WORK TOWARDS
STRATEGICALLY IDENTIFYING.
CURRENT AND DEVELOPING NEW
INITIATIVES THAT WILL INCREASE
STUDENT SAFETY AND HEALTH BY CAL
FRESH.
AGAIN I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
HEARTFELT GRATITUDE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AND TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CAMPUS CLIMATE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE. THANK
YOU.
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND TEAR WEBER
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MATTHEW I AM A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT CSU STANISLAUS AND
SERVICE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
HOUSE SEATS UNION SAYS SHE A
CHEN WHICH REPRESENTS ALL
STUDENTS IN THE CSU SYSTEM.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
EVERYONE FOR THEIR WORK TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF CAMPUS CLIMATE
AND PARTICULARLY BASIC NEEDS.
OUR STUDENTS ARE GREATLY
IMPACTED BY OUR EFFORTS AND I
WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU DO ON A DAILY
BASIS ABOUT EQUITABLE STUDENT
SUCCESS.
BEFORE DIVING INTO THE TOPIC OF
BASIC MEANS I'D LIKE TO TOUCH ON
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
TOUCH CAMPUS CLIMATE.
RECENT ACTS OF RACISM AND
PREJUDICE ON CSU CAMPUSES HAVE
REVEALED PUBLICLY WHAT STUDENTS
OF COLORHAVE LONG EXPERIENCE IN
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY.
AND ALTHOUGH THESE INCIDENTS ARE
NOT UNIQUE TO THE CSU SYSTEM.
THEY DEMONSTRATE OUR CAMPUSES
ARE NOT IMMUNE TO THE CHALLENGES
OF SYSTEMIC RACISM TO ENDANGER
THE SAFETY AND INCLUSION OF
STUDENTS AT OUR CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES AND SPECIFICALLY
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
CSU STUDENT HEALTH WELLNESS AND
SAFETY REPORT. THREATS ALLOW
THIS AND SAFETY ARE MOST
PREVALENT AMONG STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
INCIDENTS AT THERE'S A CALL SALT
ON NON WHITE STUDENTS WERE MORE
THAN TWICE AS HIGH AS THEIR
WHITE STUDENT COUNTERPARTS.
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR WERE MORE
LIKELY TO REPORT BEING VERBALLY
THREATENED AND FEELING THAT
DISCRIMINATION IMPEDED THEIR
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE.
THE CSU SYSTEM LEADS THE NATION
IN MANY WAYS OF WHAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS SHOULD BE PROUD.
WE SHOULD ALSO LEAD IN
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES CAUSED BY
SYSTEMIC RACISM ON OUR CAMPUSES.
SO THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION.
AND QUALITY CANNOT EXIST WHILE
ANY STATE STUDENT AS STEREOTYPES
ARE TARGETED BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE.
FACING RACISM PREJUDICE AND
IGNORANCE IN OUR SOCIETY LET
ALONE IN OUR PLACES OF LEARNING
HAS OBVIOUS INEQUITABLE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AND MENTAL WELL BEING OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
WE ALSO SEE THAT STUDENTS OF
COLOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
FORMER FOSTER YOU. FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE BARRIERS WHEN
IT COMES TO STUDENT HOUSING AND
SECURITY. ACCORDING TO THIS YES
USE BASIC NEEDS ARE PART
RELEASED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
AS YOU'VE HEARD WHILE SYSTEM
WIDE WHILE FORTY ONE POINT SIX
PERCENT OF STUDENTS REPORT SOME
FORM OF FOOD INSECURITY SIXTY
FIVE POINT NINE PERCENT OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS REPORT SOME
FORM OF FOOD INSECURITY.
AMONG OUR STUDENTS ARE
CLASSIFIED AS UNDERSERVED THEIR
RATES OF FOOD INSECURITY OR MEAN
HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE.
THIS MEANS AS WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THE WORK MUST
BE DONE INTENTIONALLY AND WITH
THE STATE'S DEDICATION TO EQUITY
AT THE FOREFRONT.
UNFORTUNATELY FAR TOO MANY OF
OUR CSU STUDENTS EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS.
TEN POINT NINE PERCENT OF
STUDENTS SYSTEM WINE THAT'S
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS.
REPORTED BEING HOMELESS SOMETIME
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR. AND AGAIN
OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS REPORTED
HIGHER THAN AVERAGE NUMBERS
EIGHTEEN PERCENT.
I PROBABLY DON'T HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT WHEN YOU'RE HOMELESS
TURNING IN THAT PAPER ON TIME
ATTENDING CLASS PARTICIPATING
HIGH IMPACT PRACTICES IS
PROBABLY THE LAST THING ON YOUR
MIND.
WE APPRECIATE THE PASSIONATE
WORK OF MANY LEGISLATORS WHO
RECOGNIZE THE SEVERITY OF BASIC
NEEDS AND SECURITIES ON OUR
CAMPUS SAYS. FOR EXAMPLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COPIERS AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOR THE
EMERGENCY STUDENT HOUSING LOAN
PROGRAM WOULD CREATE A PILOT
RAPID RE HOUSING PROGRAM FOR
THREE YEARS AT THREE CSU
CAMPUSES. TO ASSIST STUDENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING SIGNIFICANT
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEMS.
WE KNOW THAT MANY STUDENTS WHO
BONTA HOMELESSNESS DO SO BECAUSE
A SHORT TERM FINANCIAL
EMERGENCY.
GIVING THESE INDIVIDUAL SHORT
TERM FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND THIS
CASE RESIDENTIAL RENTAL PAYMENTS
FOR UP TO TWELVE MONTHS.
WE'LL PUT THEM IN A POSITION TO
BECOME FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT
AGAIN I TAKE ON THE COST OF
THEIR LIVING SITUATION AS THEY
COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE.
THIS TAKES US THE LAST IF SHE
DAHLE BE MENTIONING TODAY MENTAL
HEALTH.
ALL THESE ISSUES SEEM TO RELATE
TO ONE ANOTHER IF YOU'RE HAVING
TROUBLE FINDING HOUSING YOU'RE
PROBABLY STRUGGLING TO FEED
YOURSELF AS WELL.
AND IF YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OUR FOOD AND
SECURITY YOU WANT OUT OF WE HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH.
OF COURSE THERE ARE OTHER
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES TO. THE
DIFFICULTY OF THEIR STUDIES
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS IN THE
NATIONAL CLIMATE.
INTERPERSONAL ISSUES WITH FAMILY
FRIENDS ARMY ANTIC PARTNERS.
THESE FACTORS ARE ALL LINKED AND
LAYERED.
STUDENTS HAVE WORKED HARD FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS TO TRY TO
EXPAND MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
ON OUR CAMPUSES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH.
WE KNOW THAT THE NATIONAL
STANDARD FOR MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS
IS ONE MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR
PER FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS.
HOWEVER ONLY THIRTEEN NUMBER
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES HAVE
ANYTHING CLOSE TO YOU OR UNDER
THAT RANGE.
AND AT SOME CAMPUSES THERE YOU
SEE THE RATIO IS MUCH HIGHER. AT
FRESNO STATE SAN FRANCISCO STEAK
HOUSE DE LA THE RATIOS ONE
COUNSELOR TO MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS SO TWICE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
THESE RATIOS MEAN ON MANY
CAMPUSES TO DEAL WITH THE LACK
OF MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS
STUDENTS ARE PART WAIT TIMES OF
UP TO A MONTH TO SEE A COUNSELOR
IN PERSON AND A CAP ON THEIR
VISITS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
NO STUDENT WHEN THEY FOUND THE
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES SHOULD HAVE TO WAIT SO
LONG AND HAVE SUCH A LACK OF
ACCESS THE HELP THEY NEED TO BE
SAFE AND SUCCESSFUL ON THEIR
CAMPUS.
LASTLY ON THIS TOPIC ON ALL
CAMPUSES STUDENT FEES ARE BEING
USED TO PAY FOR THESE MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCE SAYS. THIS MEANS
THAT THE MOST OBVIOUS WAY TO
EXPAND THESE RESOURCES ON CAMPUS
IS TO INCREASE THESE CAMPUS
BASED FEES.
BUT THIS ONLY COMPOUNDS THE
CYCLE OF AFFORDABILITY MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES.
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
FOOD COSTS HOUSING COSTS AND
TUITION AND CAMPUS BASED VIEW
THAT CONTINUE TO RISE.
IF THE ONLY SOLUTION WITH
RESPECT MENTAL HEALTH IS TO
EXACERBATE ANOTHER ISSUE THAT IS
NOT A SOLUTION THAT TRULY HELP
STUDENTS.
GREAT WORK IS BEING DONE ON MANY
OF OUR CAMPUSES TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HOUSING AND SECURITY.
FROM ONSITE FOOD PANTRIES
WORKING WORKSHOPS TEACHING
STUDENTS HOW TO SIGN UP FOR CAL
FRESH BENEFITS AND APPS THAT
ALERT STUDENTS FOR THEIR
LEFTOVERS FROM CATERED EVENTS ON
CAMPUS.
CSU CAMPUSES ARE TAKEN UP THE
CHALLENGE OF MEETING STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS SO THEY CAN EXILE.
AND I BELIEVE THEY'RE MAKING
GOOD PROGRESS.
STILL THERE IS WORK LEFT TO DO
AND IT MUST BE DONE WITH A FOCUS
ON EQUITY. TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
WITH THE MOST NEED ORGAN SOLID
FOUNDATION TO SUCCEED.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
ALLOWING IS HERE TODAY FOR
WORKING HARD
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF EQUITY
IN STUDENT SUCCESS AND SHARE
BEST PRACTICES ACROSS THE STATE.
ALL OF THESE ISSUES ARE
INTERTWINED I FEEL PRIVILEGED TO
WORK ALONGSIDE ALL OF YOU AND
TRYING TO SOLVE THESE ISSUES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH STAY IN
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS THINK OF
US OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU RIPLEY'S WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LIMON THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ITEMIF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THIS PANEL.
.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE
QUESTIONS JUST COMMENTS I KNOW
THAT YESTERDAY WE HAD A SOMEWHAT
OF A BRIEFING ON SOME OF THE
WORK THE CAL STATE IS DOING IN
LAST WEEK.
I WAS AT CAL STATE CHANNEL
ISLANDS AND TALKING TO STUDENTS
THERE ABOUT SOME OF THE BASIC
NEEDS AND.
IT WAS INSPIRED TO HEAR SOME OF
THE INNOVATIVE IDEAS THAT I
THINK ARE COMING.
A FORWARD A PARTICULAR AROUND
TEMPORARY HOUSING OPTIONS THAT
THE HOUSE OF THE CAMPUSES ARE
PROVIDING AND SO THAT WAS A
REALLY. GOOD TO HEAR ON
PARTICULAR AS I HEARD FROM A
STUDENT TO LAUGH TALKS ABOUT HOW
HARD IT IS TO BE HOMELESS AND
HAVE TO SLEEP IN YOUR CAR AND
HOW THAT'S CONSIDERED A CRIME IN
A LOT OF THE CITIES. NEAR THE
UNIVERSITY SO I THINK YOU.
WANT TO THANK YOU.
I'D WE'VE GOT YOUR LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH I THINK
ARE VERY IMPORTANT AS WE. AS WE
DO IT APPEARED KIND OF A COSTLY
FINDING OURSELVES GOING THROUGH
THE VARIOUS BE AREAS THAT EXIST
OF THE THAT WE CAN LEGISLATIVELY
REMOVED. IN ORDER TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE CAMPUSES TO
WRESTLE WITH THE ISSUES.
WE DID DO SOME FUNDING LAST
YEAR I'M NOT SURE IF WE'LL BE
DOING I HOPE WILL BE DOING SOME
THIS YEAR AGAIN. AS AN INCENTIVE
TO THE CAMPUSES TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF OF FOOD INSECURITY AND
AND HOMELESSNESS.
BECAUSE IT IS A MAJOR ISSUE WE
WE DELIVERED UP HERE OF COURSE
WE HAVE.
SERIOUS ISSUES OF HOUSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE COST
OF HOUSING AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON SO IT'S A MAJOR ISSUE IN AND.
SOMETIMES YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE THINK OF
THEY ALL LIVE IN THE DORM WHICH
IS NOT TRUE AND SO AS A RESULT
THAT MAKES IT THAT WE HAVE TO
BREAK DOWN THAT. THAT THAT CYCLE
OF THINKING ESPECIALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO DORMITORIES THAT'LL
SOME OF YOUR CAMPUSES HAVE.
.
THE C. ISSUE I HAVE HAVE SET
ASIDE ROOMS IN THE DORM TO DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS.
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS SO YOU HAVE
AT LEAST ACCESS TO THAT ISSUE
THAT SEVERE.
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO TO DO
THAT.
OF SOMETIMES I SEE ISSUE IN
UC'S HAVE A FEW MORE RESOURCES
THAT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
BECAUSE OF THE STRUCTURE OF
THOSE CAMPUSES. AND THE
ASSUMPTIONS WE MAKE ABOUT THE
FOUR YEAR COLLEGE VERSUS THE TWO
YEAR COLLEGE WITH REGARDS TO
HOUSING IN FUNDING IN THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS. AND I THINK
WE'LL NEED TO START LOOKING AT
THAT MORE CAREFULLY INTO A
PARTICULAR IN TERMS OF THE
GRANTS THAT WE GIVE ALL WE
ASSUME IT'S CHEAPER TO GO TO A
COMMUNICABLE IT. AND TECHNICALLY
IT IS IF YOU ONLY LOOK AT. WHAT
THE FEES AND AND BOOKS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE ASKED TO OFTENTIMES
LIVE? AND.
AND TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
AT THAT POINT IT BECOMES MORE
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE OUR
DORMITORIES A CHEAPER THAN
APARTMENTS AND. IT WAS TO GET
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS VERSUS
THE TWO SO. WHAT WE'RE BUT WE'VE
WHERE WHERE THAT THE AT THIS
LEVEL WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO? HOW
TO RESPOND TO IT IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE OF BECAUSE I
OFTENTIMES THE IMAGES WE HAVE?
DICTATE POLICIES THAT THAT ARE
NOT BENEFICIAL AND SO.
WILL BEEN PLEASE WITH YOU WITH
THAT SO THANKS FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE STUDY
THAT WAS DONE YES.
AND CAN I JUST MENTION ONE THING
JUST TO KIND OF PIGGY BACK OFF
WHAT I'M CALLING SIDE FROM THE
CCC IS ABOUT CAL FRESH.
IF THERE IS A WAY TO EVEN
EXPAND THE RESTAURANT MEALS
PROGRAM TO COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT
BE WONDERFUL TO CONSIDER AND
THEN ALSO THE EBT APPLICATION
FOR CAMPUS IT'S BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THE APPLICATION IS NOT SET
FOR COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
AND IT THERE'S INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING ASKED ON THERE
THAT'S VERY HARD FOR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES TO.
ADDRESS SO IF THERE IS A WAY
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO EITHER
MAKE THAT.
APPLICATION.
A LITTLE BIT MORE FOCUSED FOR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES SO THAT MORE OF
OUR CAMPUSES CAN'T APPLY AND GET
APPROVED THAT WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL.
OKAY WILL HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE
APPLICATION FOR CAO FRESH IS NOT
BEEN IS NOT TAILORED FOR STUDENT
RIGHT IT'S FOR RETAILERS.
THAT IF JEFFREY BT I'M SORRY
CARVE OUT FOR EDT IT'S FOR YOU
KNOW RETAILERS CORNER STORE IT'S
MARKETS. AND SO YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE FIRST QUESTIONS ON THERE IS
LIKE WHAT KIND OF RETAILER ARE
YOU OR YOUR SOLE PROPRIETOR ARE
YOU. AND SO OUR CAMPUSES DON'T
NECESSARILY FALL INTO THAT SO
THERE'S BEEN SOME CAN SOME
CONFUSION A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION AROUND THAT. AND THEN
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT ASK FOR
A PERSON SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
AND DRIVERS LICENSE SO THAT
MEANS SOMEONE ON OUR CAMPUS HAS
TO DO TO DO THAT OR GIVE THAT
INFORMATION AND IT. SO MAYBE IF
THERE'S WAYS THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THAT A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY ON THE
APPLICATION SO THAT IT OPENS IT
UP MORE BECAUSE IF WE'RE
ENCOURAGING OUR STUDENTS FOR CAL
TRASH. AND THEN THEY HAVE TO GO
OFF CAMPUS TO USE THOSE DOLLARS.
YOU NOTE SOMETIMES THAT THE
BARRIERS WELL ESPECIALLY MORE
RULE COMMUNITIES WHERE MAYBE
THERE'S NOT A STORE THAT'S
NEARBY MAYBE ONLY HAVE AN HOUR
IN BETWEEN CLASS.
SO JUST THINKING ABOUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN KEEP OUR STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS AND FOCUS ON THEIR SCHOOL
WORK. DON'T SOME OF YOU CAMPUS
IS YOU HAVE EBT CARDS YEAH WE
HAVE SIX CAMPUSES THAT OFFER EBT
ON CAMPUS OKAY AND THE OTHERS
DON'T BECAUSE JUST BECAUSE
EITHER THE APPLICATION IS A
LITTLE DIFFICULT TO GET THROUGH
OR THERE'S QUESTIONS AROUND AT
SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
APPLIED AND IT'S. A PROCESS
WHERE THEY HAVE THEY MAKE IT
DENIED FOR SOME REASON AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO APPLY AGAIN I
BELIEVE IF YOU'RE DENIED.
ARE NOT APPROVED TWICE YOU HAVE
TO WAIT A YEAR BEFORE YOU CAN
APPLY AND. SO EVEN HAVE ANY
CONNECTION I'M WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD THAT CONNECTION NOW BUT TO
HAVE A CONNECTION TO SOMEONE.
WITHIN THE U. S. C. A. TO HELP
COLLEGE CAMPUSES SPECIFICALLY
YEAH LIAISON TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS THAT COULD BE HELPFUL
WILL LOOK INTO THAT YEAH BECAUSE
I KNOW WE.
.
EBT CARDS HAVE BEEN A BIG ISSUE
APPEAR WITH THAT WITH REGARD TO
THAT AND AND GETTING THE
LEGISLATION THROUGH.
TO MAKE SURE THE CAMPUSES CAN.
THEY CAN GET THE CAN USE EBT
CARDS ON CAMPUS FIRST OF ALL
THAT WAS A MAJOR CHALLENGE.
AND THEN.
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE COUNTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE CAL FRESH IN
THEIR COUNTIES OF THE STUDENTS
ON THE CAMPUSES CAN STILL APPLY.
MACAU FIRST BECAUSE IT THAT
COVERED BY THE STATE SO WE'VE
DONE SOME OF THOSE THINGS WILL
HAVE TO KEEP LOOKING AS YOU FIND
BE AREAS LET US KNOW BECAUSE
THAT. OFTENTIMES MAKE IS GOING
TO ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
BECAUSE WE THINK WE'VE SOLVED
THE PROBLEM AND IF THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S MISSING OR
GLITCHES SOMETHING.
WE CAN TRY TO MAKE CONTACT WITH
THE. WITH THE WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO DEAL WITH IT AND AND AND LET
THEM KNOW THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH THE APPLICATION. OF AND HOW
LONG IT TAKES AND SO FORTH AND
SO ON SO. NOW WILL LOOK INTO
THAT WILL LOOK INTO THAT MADE
AND I CAN FOLLOW UP I CONTINUED
YEAH FOLLOW UP WITH THAT WITH MY
STAFF ON THAT BECAUSE WE. YOU
KNOW AT ONE OF THINGS WE
DISCOVERED ABOUT THE THIS ISSUE
IS THAT OUT.
EVERYTHING LOOKS UP WAS NOT.
THAT'S REAL CLEAR AND.
AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU CAN
SEE THE FOOD ON THE TABLE BUT
YOU CAN GET THERE TO GET IT. AND
SO THAT'S A BIG CHALLENGE THAT
WE HAVE.
NOTED PARTICULAR IN THIS STATE
SO WE'VE GOT A LOT OF RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT IT WOULD NOT
DESIGNED FOR. MOST CAMPUSES AND
SO WE'RE GOING TO.
WE'RE MOVING SLOWLY BUT SURELY
TO ADDRESS THOSE SOLD WILL BE IN
TEXAS HE WILL WE NEED TO DO TO
BASICALLY MAKE THAT APPLICATION
PROCESS. EASIER AND A MORE OPEN
AND FASTER IN TERMS OF
PROCESSING.
AS WELL AS A OF THE RESTAURANT
MEALS PROGRAM AS IT SHOULD BE AT
EVERY CAMPUS YES OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S HEAR FROM MY UC
CAMPUS.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY OF FROM
ARE YOU SEE CAMPUS WE HAVE
REUBEN COULD NATO FLU IS THAT
THE.
.
YOU SEE SYSTEMS BAKE SYDNEY
CULTURE FROM UC BERKELEY.
TIM GOLLUM.
THE LIMO. ASSESSMENT TELL ME IN
A BILL ARE NO FILLER NO OKAY TO
LEARN HOW TO LEARN A FROM UC
SANTA CRUZ RIGHT.
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN AN ISSUE THAT
RACHEL.
SUMAC.
OKAY WHO IS EXECUTIVE IN. AND
DIRECTED FOUND OF SWIPE OUT
HUNGER. AND YOU SEE A LOT HILL
I'M NOT WHO WILL SPEAK TO US
UNLESS WE HAVE DOMINIQUE
WILLIAMS A CURRENT STUDENT FROM
UC BERKELEY AND PART OF THE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. WHEN YOU
SEE WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
TRY EACH ONE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
THE FIVE MINUTES YOU HAVE A
LARGER PANEL THANK YOU.
IT WOULD RUIN OUR OWE YOU GUYS
DECIDE WAS THE START.
SO WE'RE GOOD AND TIM ARE
TOGETHER OKAY YEAH GETTING GROUP
THAT ATTACKED HIM OKAY THIS.
OKAY SO.
THEY GOT SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TODAY.
AND THAT TAKES TESTIFIED IN I'M
I'M RUBEN DOES MY BROTHER TIM
RIGHT HERE.
WE GO TO THE SYSTEM WIDE BASIC
NEEDS EFFORT AND HAVE WORKED ON
THE IMPACT MEASUREMENT AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
ACROSS ALL TEN OF OUR CAMPUSES.
YEAH THANK YOU TO WHOEVER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON I'M FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY HOW WE DID
THIS KICKOFF YESTERDAY THE
EDUCATION FINANCE COMMITTEE AND
I'M GOING DEEPER AND BRING THESE
ISSUES TO LIGHT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION. SAYS RUBIN NOTED
OUR OUR TEN CAMPUS IN USE UP CHO
COORDINATION AS THE INTERLOPERS
FOR BASIC NEEDS EFFORT. WE'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITIES TO LISTEN
AND LEARN TO OUR STUDENTS
GRADUATE UNDERGRADUATE
PROFESSIONAL. ON TO OUR STAFF
AND FACULTY IN AS WELL TO HELP
CREATE IMAGES OF WHAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH TOGETHER AND WE'RE
HERE TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF
OUR EFFORTS TO DATE. AND THIS IS
INCLUDE LAUNCHING IN SCALING UP
NUTRITIOUS INTEREST BASED FOOD
PANTRIES ON ALL CAMPUSES.
INCREASING ACCESS TO FOOD
PROVISIONING IN PREPARATION
WORKSHOPS AND SERVICES.
SPENDING SO ABOUT HUNGER
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW YOU SEE
STUDENTS TO DONATE EXCESS MEAL
PLAN DOLLARS.
STUDENTS IN NEED ON ALL CAMPUSES
ESTABLISHING COLLABORATIONS WITH
STATING COUNTY OFFICES TO
REGISTER STUDENTS FOR CALTRANS.
CITY CALIFORNIA'S NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ENHANCING
FINANCIALLY COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT
HOUSING AND FOOD COSTS AMONG
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES TO OUR
STUDENTS AND ALL TEN CAMPUSES.
SO FEDERAL FUNDING LOW'S STATE
FUNDING LOS CONSISTENT INCREASE
INSTITUTIONAL CROSSING
CONSISTENT INCREASE COST OF
LIVING. MAKE TODAY'S COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
AND THE SUPPORT ITS IS THE
CREATION OF FEDERAL PELL GRANT
AND SEVENTY TWO.
AS WORK IN FOOD SECURITY
PROGRESS HE BECAME CLEAR THAT
INSECURITY WAS JUST ONE
COMPONENT OF A LARGER SPECTRUM
OF A BASIC NEEDS FRAMEWORK. THAT
MUST TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
UNIQUE HARDSHIPS PRESENTED BY
THE OVERALL COST OF ATTENDANCE
FOR STUDENTS INCLUDING FOOD.
HOUSING AND WELLNESS RELATED
EXPENSES.
AND DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
PUBLISHED OUR LARGEST THAT HE TO
DATE THE UC STUDENT FOOD HOUSING
SECURITY STUDY. HERE SOME OF THE
MAJOR LESSONS WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM THE OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE AND OVER SIX
THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENT
PARTICIPANTS.
NUMBER ONE WHERE ADDRESSING A
GENERAL UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION
FACING FORTY FOUR PERCENT LOW IN
VERY LOW FOOD SECURITY. BY
UTILIZING A MULTI FACTOR
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE THE MOST
AT RISK GROUPS AND PRIORITIZING
SUPPORT STRATEGIES FOR THEM.
TWENTY SIX PERCENT OF GRADUATE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCED FOOD
INSECURITY DURING THE ACADEMIC
YEAR. WE HAVE DEVELOPED BETTER
GUIDANCE SYSTEMS FOR CAL FRESH
BENEFIT ENROLLMENT AND
QUALIFICATION FOR GRADUATE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS MULTI FACTOR
ANALYSES. TO IDENTIFIED THE
GREATER ASKS RISK GROUPS.
FIVE PERCENT OF UNDERGRADUATE
AND GRADUATE STUDENTS SELF
REPORTING EXPENSING HOMELESSNESS
AT SOME POINT OF THE ACADEMIC
YEAR CONSISTENTLY BLACK NATIVE
AMERICAN FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
TRANSFER STUDENTS STUDENTS IN
HUMANITIES. AND ADVANCE FOURTH
FIFTH YEAR STUDENTS HAVE MUCH
HIGHER RATES OF HOMELESSNESS
THEIR HOMELESSNESS RATES VARY
FROM EIGHT TO THIRTEEN PERCENT.
ADDRESSING BASIC NEEDS HAS A
NOTABLE EFFECT ON ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AND ACHIEVEMENT.
DATA FROM OUR ANALYSIS INDICATES
MAJORITY OF UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING BOTH FOOD
INSECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS WERE
BELOW THE THREE POINT OH GPA.
WHICH IS A DIRECT IMPACT ON
THEIR ON AND OFF CAMPUS
STUDENT EMPLOYABILITY ACCESS TO
RESEARCH PROGRAMS AND POST
GRADUATION OPPORTUNITIES.
ONLY SEVENTY PERCENT OF GRADUATE
STUDENTS WERE EXPANSIVELY
SECURITY HOMELESSNESS REPORT
BEING ON TRACK TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE ON TIME COMPARED WITH
EIGHTY TWO PERCENT OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE BOTH FOOD AND HOUSING
SECURE.
AS BRIEFLY OVERVIEW HERE IF WE
CONTINUE TO APPLY OUR RESEARCH
FINDINGS WHICH STUDENT WHAT'S
TARGETED STRATEGIC SUPPORT
SERVICES.
AND SO RESEARCH IS ONLY ONE PART
OF OUR BASIC NEEDS MODEL WE HAVE
FOUR AREAS THAT SHAPE.
OUR SUPPLEMENTAL SLIDES WE
PROVIDE A CAN GIVE A DIAGRAM OF
THE AREAS.
THAT WERE ENGAGING IN BASIC
NEEDS EFFORTS COLLECTIVELY.
SO THOSE EFFORTS ALSO INCLUDE
CAMPUS PREVENTION MODELS AS WELL
THE SUSTAINABILITY IN TERMS OF
INSTITUTIONALIZING BEST
PRACTICES IN INFORMING EFFECTIVE
ADVOCACY TO SUPPORT BASIC NEED
SECURITY FOR ALL STUDENTS.
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS YOU SEE
PRESIDENT PAUL TANA'S INVESTED
OVER FOUR MILLION TO OUR
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS.
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR WE ALSO
RECEIVED TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
IN FUNDING FROM THE STATE FOR
THE HUNGER FREE CAMPUS
INITIATIVE.
HER INVESTMENT IN THE COLLECTIVE
LEADERSHIP OVER CAMPUS AND
SYSTEMWIDE LEADERS HAVE PRODUCED
THE FOLLOWING RESULTS TO DATE.
SO YOU SEE IT PUBLISHES RUBIN
NOTED THE LARGEST STUDY AND FOR
YOUR RESEARCH UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES OF STUDENT FOOD AND
HOUSING SECURITY WITH BOTH
QUANTITATIVE ANALYSIS OF FOOD
INSECURITY RISK FACTORS. COUPLE
QUALITATIVE STUDIES AND LIVED
EXPERIENCES FROM OUR STUDENTS
THEMSELVES.
FURTHER WE'VE INTEGRATED FOOD
SECURITY QUESTIONS THAT'S WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM WIDE STUDENT SURVEY
TOOLS IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
MEASURE LEVELS OF INSECURITY IN
THE STERN EXPERIENCE.
FOR ALL YOU SEE CAMPUSES TO DATE
WE'VE ESTABLISHED INSTITUTIONAL
BASIC NEEDS COMMITTEES COMPRISED
OF STAFF FACULTY UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS AND GRADUATE STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
IF CENTRALIZED BASIC NEED
RESOURCES ONLINE WITH WEB SITES
THAT ARE MORE ACCEPTABLE IN
STREAMLINED.
WE'VE CREATED HEALTHY CHOICE
BASED PANTRIES WITH SUPPLEMENTAL
OF THAT INSIGHT BASED
DISTRIBUTION SERVICES TO TARGET
EVENTS INSIGHTS AT A HIGHER RISK
POPULATION SO WE CAN GO TO OUR
STUDENTS ARE THAT NEED THE
SUPPORT.
OUR CALVET SUPPLICATION
ENROLLMENT EFFORTS HAVE INCLUDED
ON SITE COORDINATION. WITH OUR
COUNTY AN NGO PARTNERS TO
IMPROVE THE STUDENT ENROLLMENT
SEX
SUCCESS RATE IS ALL THE ONLINE
APPLICATION PARTNERSHIPS WITH
CODE FOR AMERICA SO WE
STREAMLINED AND UP THE COAST IN
THIRTY TO TEN MINUTES.
TO ROLL STUDENTS AND NOW THE US
ARE SEVEN REVISION WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS TO RENEW IN THREE
MINUTES.
THIS IS REALLY EXCITING FOR THE
STUDENT PROCESS AS YOU KNOW TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE OF STUDENTS
BETWEEN CLASSES AND WHAT NOT.
IN A BASIC NEED SKILL
DEVELOPMENT WORKSHOPS AND
TRAINING FOR FINANCIAL LITERACY
TO FOOD PREPARATION AND
PROVISIONING ARE FEATURED ON
EVERY TEN OF OUR CAMPUSES.
AND AT PRESENT FIVE OF THE TEN
UC CAMPUSES HAVE GONE FURTHER BY
LAUNCHING A MULTI FUNCTION BASIC
NEEDS CENTER TO CENTRALIZE THE
NEEDS AND INFORMATION SERVICES
FOR STUDENTS. WITH ALL CAMPUS IS
COMMITTED TO ESTABLISHING CENTER
IS BY TWENTY TWENTY.
WE PROVIDED INPUT AND SUPPORT
THE RESEARCH AND STUDENT
TESTIMONIALS THE STATE ASSEMBLY
BILL PROCESS SEES FROM AB
NINETEEN THIRTY. SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN TO FOURTEEN IN AB FOUR
FIFTY THREE AND AGAIN WE WE
THANK BOTH OF OUR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE HERE FOR HEARING THE
STUDENTS. AND THE COMMUNITY IN
RESPONDING WITH EFFECTIVE AND
TIMELY ACTION.
SO AS PART OF THE HUNDRED FREE
CAMPUS EACH PUBLICAR DUCATION
SECTOR WAS AWARDED TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION.
IN THE UC CAMPUS WE AWARDED
THOSE EQUAL OCCASIONS TO THE TEN
CAMPUSES A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WITH PROGRAMMATIC FOLKS
IT FOCUSES ON EMERGENCY MEALS
CAL FRESH OUT REACH ENROLLMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND PROGRAM
STAFFING SUPPORT SO SURE
YESTERDAY IN THE SENATE
EDUCATION FINANCE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PAUL FUNDS WILL BE
EXPENDED ON THIS FOCUS.
FOR THE STUDENT LEVEL. WHILE
CONTINUES TO GROW AND SO WE SEEK
TO EXPLORE PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
STATE TO ADVANCE OUR BASIC NEEDS
SECURE AGENDA FOR STUDENTS.
AND I JUST WANNA ADDITIONAL
NOTRE INTER SEGMENTAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE CCC IN CS
YOU COULD BE STRONGER THAN THEY
ARE TODAY IT'S IT'S PART OF OUR
DRIVE ME COMING HERE AND SEEING
OUR.
A PARTNERS COLLEEN ENTITIES AND
OUR STUDENTS NEED IS ALTOGETHER
THINK INCREASE THE VILLAGE FEEL
THAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT.
FULL SQUAT IN THE BUILDING
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE LIKE TO
SEE.
SO THAT.
THE CONSTANT BASIC NEEDS IN
SECURITIES A IT'S IT'S IT'S A
SYSTEMIC CHALLENGE.
STUDENT FINANCIAL FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURE WILL NOT
CORRECT ITSELF
OUR RESEARCH HAS IDENTIFIED KEY
INTERVENTIONS TO SUPPORT COLLEGE
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS WE CAN
IMPROVE ON THAT THREE KEY OF THE
FOLLOWING THE EDUCATION A MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
ABOUT PERSON ON COLLEGE FINANCES
AS WELL AS SKILLS THAT WILL
SUPPORT THEIR BASIC NEEDS
THROUGH COLLEGE AND BEYOND.
PREVENTION SERVICES AND STAFFING
TO IMPROVE ON BOARDING AND
SUPPORT THROUGH GRADUATION OF
OUR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS.
AND STATE FUNDING FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
FACT THAT IN OUR STATE WE
PROVIDE MORE FUNDING PER STATE
PRISONER THEM PER STATE COLLEGE
STUDENT.
WE MUST LEAD AS A STATE THE CALL
TO REINVEST IN PUBLIC HIGH
DUCATION AS WE DID DURING THE
CREATION OF THE GI BILL IN THE
FEDERAL PELL GRANT.
THE GENERATIONS OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
AND NINETEEN SEVENTIES COULD
WORK TEN HOURS A WEEK DURING
SCHOOL IN THIRTY FIVE HOURS A
WEEK DURING SUMMER. TO FULLY
COVER THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE
TODAY'S STUDENTS WORKING THOSE
EXACT SAME OUR CAN ONLY PAY FOR
ONE THIRD OF THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
THERE MORE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS LOW INCOME AND
WORKING CLASS STUDENTS STUDENTS
OF COLOR STUDENT PARENTS AND
ADULTS STUDENTS TODAY THAN EVER
BEFORE. EACH OF THESE
INTERSECTIONAL IDENTITIES
PROVIDE EXPERIENTIAL
GENERATIONAL WISDOM THAT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE INNOVATION
IMPROVEMENT OF OUR CITIES
COUNTIES AND STATE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
CLOSELY WITH YOU TO MAKE OUR
STATE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM BASIC NEED TO CARE
EQUITABLE SUCCESSFUL AND THE
GLOBAL STANDARD OF EXCELLENCE.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU MENTIONED
BEFORE THAT YOU WANTED TO SEE
SPECIFIC WAYS THAT THE STATE CAN
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT. END UP AND.
SLIGHT DIG THAT WE CREATED FOR
YOU WE ISOLATED THE LAST LIKE
DID YOU JUST GIVE YOU THOSE
SPECIFIC AREAS THAT WERE HAPPY
TO HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS IF
HE WANTED TO.
GOOD LOOKS GOOD THANK YOU
ALRIGHT RACHEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
MEAN TO BE ON THIS PANEL AND TO
SPEAK AT THIS HEARING STATE
SOMEONE RUBBER. IT IS AN
INCREDIBLE HONOR AND I. COME TO
THE TABLE YES AS A YOU SEE ELLIE
ALONE BOTH THE PERSPECTIVE TODAY
AS THE CEO AND COFOUNDER OF
SWIPE AT HOME VERY WHICH IS A
NATIONAL INDEPENDENT FIVE A ONE.
SEE THREE NONPROFIT WHICH FOR
THE PAST EIGHT YEARS HAS BEEN
PARTNERING WITH UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES TO ADDRESS COLLEGE
STUDENT HUNGER. IN THAT TIME
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SCALE TO
DOZENS OF COLLEGES ACROSS
NINETEEN STATES SERVING ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION MEALS AND YOU
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH. THE STATE ASSEMBLY ON
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY THREE WHICH
BECAME SB EIGHTY FIVE ON THE
HUNGER FOR CAMPUS SPELL.
ANYTHING THE MOST INSPIRING PART
OF ALL OF IT IS HOW.
THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S SPOKEN
TODAY HOW MUCH OF AN IMPACT THE
FUNDING IS MADE AND WE REALLY
HOPE TO SEE THAT WE GET SHARED
IF NINE PIECE IN THE COMING UP
IN THE COMING YEAR.
I WAS THE ONLY PERSON SPEAKING
TODAY WHO IS NOT EMPLOYEES OR A
STUDENT OF THE STATE I. WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS IS ALSO PART OF THE PUBLIC
CITIZEN AND EYES AND NONPROFIT
WHO HAS SEEN THIS WORK APPEN
ACROSS THE STATE AND KNOWS. BUT
THE VALUE OF BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE SYSTEM BEING SHARED
IS SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
WHENEVER THERE'S MONEY ON THE
TABLE TO DROP PEOPLE TOGETHER.
AS A STUDENT AT UCLA MY FRIEND
BRIAN AND I STARTED SWIPE A
HUNGER WHICH WAS A PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWED STUDENTS WHO DON'T NEED
THE EXTRA MONEY FOR THEIR MEAL
PLAN TO THEIR PEERS.
BECAUSE YOU CAN IMAGINE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN YOU SAID HE WAS
NOT A VERY BIG FAN OF THIS BUT
WITH PARTNERSHIP AND COMING
TOGETHER AROUND. A BIT OF
TEENAGE ANGST WE WERE ABLE TO
GET YOU SEE LA ON BOARD AND NOW
HAVE AS MUNCH AND SKILL ALONG TO
ALL UC'S. SUCH A DOZEN CSU'S
HALF A DOZEN CS USE AND WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
YOU HEARD FROM DOCTOR GRASS ON
MUCH MORE INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING RESOURCES.
LIKE FOR FARMERS MARKETS LIKEN
VOUCHERS AND PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE PANTIES.
THE FIRST POINT I REALLY WANT TO
URGE TODAY IS THAT THE WELL. HAS
NEVER EVER EVER BEEN MORE
OPPOSED. TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
AND THAT'S NOT JUST AMONGST THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM BUT IN
THE PUBLIC IF YOU TURN ON GOOGLE
ALERTS FOR THE PHRASE. FOOD
INSECURITY AMONG COLLEGE
STUDENTS YOU'RE GOING TO GET
SEVERAL ARTICLES EVERYDAY.
IF YOU TALK TO ANY OF THE CAMPUS
CATERERS I PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN.
A WITNESS TO HOW MULTINATIONAL
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR CORPORATIONS
LIKE AM I CONSIDER EXCEL HAVE
GONE FROM NO IS THIS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO NOW THROUGH OUR
PROGRAM. INVESTING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN YOUR
CREDITS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE TRULY SERVING ALL STUDENTS
ON CAMPUS WHEN IT COMES ACCESS
TO FOOD.
I THINK THIS BRINGS USED BY
LARGER POINT WHICH IS AS YOU FOR
TODAY FOOD IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T EXIST ON OUR CAMPUSES
IT'S ACCESSIBLE. BUT TO THINK
ABOUT PAYING TEN DOLLARS EVERY
TIME YOU ON A SALAD OR ANYTIME
YOU WANT A BURGER IS GONNA MAKE
ANYONE GO BROKE.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A LARGER CONVERSATION
AROUND PARTNERSHIP. AND FOR THE
FOOD RETAILERS THAT WE HAVE ON
CAMPUS.
IF IT'S NOT FEASIBLE TO LOWER
THE COST OFSUBSIDIZE ACOSTA LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
THEN HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
THAT CONVERSATION THAT IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE ISN'T A BARRIER TO
MEETINGS TO SHOW THAT EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO THE SAME FOOD.
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN WE RISKS WE
WOULD RECEIVE INTEREST FORMS
FROM FIVE TO SEVEN UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY EVERY MONTH.
THESE WERE ALWAYS FROM STUDENTS.
IN THE PAST YEAR FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
OVER HALF OF THE INTEREST FORMS
RECEIVE COME DIRECTLY ROM
ADMINISTRATORS AND DINING
PROFESSIONALS THEMSELVES.
WE SEE THIS IS A HUGE SHIFT IN
THE WAY ABOUT PARTNERSHIPS ARE
STARTING TO COME TOGETHER. MY
FAVORITE ANALOGY LIKE TALK ABOUT
OUR WORK IS BE IF YOU GIVE A
MANIFESTS.
RIGHT SO WE'RE GIVING WE HAVE
THESE PANTRIES.
NO NO NO IT'S GONNA ORDER.
OUR EMERGENCY SERVICES WHETHER
IT'S PENSIONS OUR MEAL VOUCHERS.
ARE GIVING OUR STUDENTS AFFAIRS.
WE'RE TEACHING OUR SCHOOLS HOW
TO FISH BY GIVING THEM THE
FUNDING AND BEST PRACTICES TO
UPDATE THE SCHOOLS THAT REFLECT
THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE PRESENT TODAY.
AND IF WE WANT TO TAKE IT ONE
STEP FURTHER. THAT'S
REVOLUTIONIZING THE FISHING
INDUSTRY HARDLY ME EXTRA FROM
THE GET GO EVERYONE HAS ACCESS
TO FINISH THAT MEANS WE BRING ON
MY ADVICE A VOTE OF NO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE CAN DO.
IS LET'S TALK ABOUT THE CONTACTS
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE SIGNING
BOTH WITH OUR FOOD PROVIDERS
WITH OUR TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS
MAKING SURE THAT.
WE HOPE OUR STUDENTS INTERESTS
BEFORE ANYONE SHAREHOLDER
INTEREST
MAKING FOR A CONTRACTOR ETHICAL
SO HOW DO WE MAKE SHOULD OWN IT
COMES TO FOOD AS A PIECE FINE.
WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS A PIPELINE PROBLEM DOESN'T
CONTINUE.
AS A CLOSING NO.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
INNOVATION AND AND PARTNERSHIP
CONTINUES TO SAY ON THE TABLE
EYES THESE BILLS COME UP I WOULD
DO THE PEOPLE MOST HUMOR SO
DEALER JAPAN. I HOPE THAT WE
DON'T SCRAP.
THING THAT WE'VE LEARNED AT
THINGS WE PUT FORWARD BUT RATHER
REALLY INVEST IN INNOVATING ON
TOP OF AMENDED RATING TO MAKE
THEM BETTER. BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MUCH LEARNING THAT HAPPENS AND
OTHER STUDENTS GO THROUGH THE
SYSTEM WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO LEARN. I WAS A STUDENT AT
STEPPED UP STARTED A PROGRAM
THAT'S NOW HELPED. DO LAST YEAR
ALONE TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
ANGER STUDENTS CONSERVE AS A
HUGE HUB OF INNOVATION BUT IT'S
NOT MY RESPONSIBILITY IT'S NOT
ANY STUDENTS TO SPONSOR BILLETED
TO HAVE TO. SUPPORT THEIR PEERS
WILL PICK IT UP WILL PUSH THE
OUTAGE WILL PUSH THE RED LINE.
BUT WE NEED TO PASS THE BATON ON
TO OUR STATE LEADERS AND I
UNIVERSITY LEADERS AND I AM SO
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP.
IN MAKING SURE THAT OUR VOICES
ARE BEING HEARD AND THAT THE
WORK CONTINUES BEYOND OUR TIME
ON CAMPUS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DOMINATE.
HELLO THIS IS ON RIGHT OKAY.
I.
SORRY I'M A STUDENT I'M NEW TO
THIS.
SO MY NAME'S ON NICKELODEON'S
AND THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DOCTOR WEBER FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
.
SO. I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
REGARDLESS SO MY TITLE IS I'M
JUST A STUDENT THAT ALMOST
WASN'T HERE TODAY AND I'LL. GET
INTO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR GO TO UC
BERKELEY.
AND ALL WILL BE MY TEST
TESTIMONY NOW.
SOME OF MY FRESHMAN YEAR I CAL.
MONIES IN FRIDAY'S I WOKE UP AT
FIVE THIRTY AND STARTED A SHIFT
IN THE DINING HALL. FINISHED AT
TEN AM WALKED HOME SO THE FIFTY
MINUTE POWER NAP UNTIL TEN
TWENTY. AND CHANGE OUT OF MY
DISCUSSING CLOSE TO GET TO MY
FIRST CLASS ACROSS CAMPUS BEFORE
TEN FORTY.
ALSO WORK WEEKENDS.
TUESDAY WEDNESDAY AND THURSDAY
I'D MISS MORNING CLASSES TO
TRAVEL TOSAN FRANCISCO TO WORK
FROM TEN AM TO SEVEN PM. NOT
GETTING HOME UNTIL EIGHT OR NINE
WITH A LOT OF CLASSES AND
SETTING TO CATCH UP ON.
I RECEIVE NO FINANCIAL ASSISTANT
FOR ASSISTANCE FROM MY PARENTS
AND STILL DON'T. NOT BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO HELP BUT
BECAUSE THEY COULD IT.
THERE WERE TIMES THAT I HAD COME
SO CLOSE TO MISSING MY REAP MY
RENT PAYMENTS.
A COUPLE TIMES I WENT OVER TO.
AT SOME POINT IN THE MIDDLE OF
MY SECOND SEMESTER MY MIL POINTS
WERE DEPLETED SAUCES SURVIVING
ON SCRAPS.
I'M OF THE NIGHT I BROKE DOWN IT
JUST WET BECAUSE I WAS SO
EXHAUSTED I WAS STRUGGLING AND I
WAS FREAKING HUNGRY.
AND LET ME TELL YOU I WAS I WAS
AT A LUCKY.
BECAUSE I STILL MADE.
I'M TALKING RECIPIENT WHICH
MEANS THAT PART OF MY TUITION IS
PAID FOR. I WAS WORKING TWO JOBS
JUST TO SCRAPE BY AND BURKE WAS
ON CAMPUS HOUSING COSTS WHICH
ARE RIDICULOUSLY HIGH.
JUST THIS PAST YEAR I STARTED TO
RECEIVE CALAVERAS WHICH IS THE
EBT PROGRAM ALLOWS LOW INCOME
PERSONS TO ACCESS FOOD.
AND I'M EXTREMELY THANKFUL FOR
THE FOR THE WORK THAT DOCTOR
WEBER DID IN OFFERING AB TWENTY
FOUR.
TO FOURTEEN LAST YEAR.
I BUT THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE
THAT AREN'T SO LUCKY. I MEMBER
CALLOUS FRIENDS AND
ACQUAINTANCES THAT MISS RIGHT
PAYMENTS AND WERE KICKED OUT OF
THEIR APARTMENTS.
THEY START AND WERE FORCED TO
DROP OUT.
THEN HOW TO KNOW HOW TO BUDGET
MANAGE MY TIME AD DIG DEEP. HOW
BE A COW AND SITTING BEFORE YOU
ALL TODAY?
I THINK THIS GOES TO SHOW ONE OF
THE MANY EXAMPLES ABOUT BECAUSE
CONTAINS YOU.
THE STRUGGLES ARE INJURED WITHIN
MY TIME HERE CAL DEVELOPED IN ME
A CERTAIN LEVEL GRAY. A
PSYCHOPATH AND TO PUSH MY
LIMITS.
I SURPRISE MYSELF CONSTANTLY
WITH HOW MUCH I CAN INDOOR AND
HAVE BEEN DOING ANY CREATES A
CERTAIN SENSE OF PRIDE IN ONE'S
OWN JOURNEY.
MOREOVER IT'S GIVING ME THE
GREAT TO BE HERE IN FRONT OF ALL
OF YOU AND TELL YOU FRANKLY THAT
NOT ENOUGH IS BEING DONE TO
ERADICATE THESE ISSUES.
BECAUSE OF MY STORY IT IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE FOR
STARVATION TO BE A COLLEGE
REQUIREMENT FOR DEGREE
ATTAINMENT.
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE FOR
HOMELESSNESS TO BE A REALITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THE PRACTICES OF EVEN TOP RAHMAN
COUCHSURFING HAD BEEN A REGULAR
PART OF THE CAUSE GOING BECAUSE
CULTURE. GETTING ONLY THE MOST
RECENT YEARS THERE HAS BEEN A
COLLECTIVE REALIZATION THAT
THESE PROBLEMS EXIST AND THEY
ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE.
INDEED IT IS CRITICAL FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS THAT HE OR SHE
HAS THE SOUND PLACE TO SLEEP
PROPERLY TO NUTRITION TO SAY
HEALTH AND FOCUS. A PROBLEM
IT'LL.
SECURITY AND SUPPORT SERVICES
TO ENGAGE A STUDIES SUCKS IT
SUCCESSFULLY IN HOLY.
THE FIRST LEVEL OF MASS LOW'S
PERIOD OF A PYRAMID OF HUMAN
NEEDS ENCOMPASSES SECURING
PHYSIOLOGICAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
BREEDING FOOD WATER SHELTER
CLOTHING AND SLEEP.
A LACK OF ACCESS TO SUCH BASIC
NEEDS IN. NOT ONLY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS SOONER SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH
AND MAKES IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO ATTAIN HIGHER EDUCATION.
GOOD ANSWER AND SECURITY HAS
BEEN LINKED TO CARDIOVASCULAR
RISK FACTORS AS WELL AS HIGHER
RATES OF DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY.
SINCE OUR STRUGGLING TO GET OUT
OF BED IF THEY HAVE ONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE SUFFERING FROM
ABSOLUTE EXHAUSTION.
NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT MY HOME
CAMPUS UC BERKELEY.
THE CROWN JEWEL OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THE STATE'S CROWN JEWEL YES YES
ODYSSEUS CROWN JEWEL DOESN'T
EVEN GUARANTEE FIRST YEAR
HOUSING TO EVERY FRESHMAN AMY
ANYMORE.
AMID A GROWING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY TOPPED
SEVERAL BE CISCO SAN FRANCISCO
GATE LIST OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
COLLEGE TOWNS IN THE COUNTRY.
SAN FRANCISCO GATES RANKING IS
BASED ON BECAUSE SOUNDS WHERE AT
LEAST TWENTY PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION IS ROLE IS ENROLLED
IN A UNIVERSITY. ANYTHING AND IS
COMPOSED OF MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
BERKELEY AT THE POPULATION OF
THIRTY POINT FIVE PERCENT
STUDENTS AND BERKELEY TOPS THIS
LIST. AMONG THE OTHER MOST
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE TOWNS SANTA
CRUZ WHICH IS ALSO ANOTHER YOU
SEE SCHOOL. CAMBRIDGE BOULDER
AND PRINCETON.
FOR CAP IS ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
OF CITY AND REGIONAL PLANNING
MODEL HUTS IN. THE REASON FOR
BERKELEY STATUS IS SUCH AN
EXPENSIVE LOCATION RESTS ON THE
LACK OF HOUSING AVAILABLE IN THE
AREA WHICH IS PERPETUATED BY THE
GREAT DEMAND TO LIVE CLOSE TO
CAMPUS.
ASIDE FROM HOUSE FROM FOOD AND
HOUSING IN SECURITY MENTAL
HEALTH IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF BASIC NEEDS.
ON MANY CAMPUSES IT TAKES WEEKS
ACCESS IN PERSON COUNSELING
SERVICES.
THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME FOR AN
APPOINTMENT ACROSS YOU SEE IS
TWENTY ONE DAYS AND ARE CAPS
USUALLY FIVE SIX VISITS HOW MANY
TIMES PER YEAR. STUDENTS CAN
RECEIVE RECEIVE HELP.
THIS TO BE MORE INVESTMENT IN
EXCESS OF BILLION OUT WE
SERVICES ON OUR CAMPUSES
AS WELL AS A HUMAN OF MORE
DIVERSE COUNTLESS REFLECT THE
STUDENT BODY CAN UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OF STUDENTS TODAY.
IN TERMS OF INSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSE TO BASIC NEEDS AND
SECURITIES THE UCC IS UC SYSTEM
ITSELF HAS DEVELOPED VERY
STRATEGIES IN ORDER TO BETTER
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
MOST OF THE STRIDES HE'S THUS
FAR ARE FOCUSED ON FOOD
SECURITY.
HOW YOU SEE MEASURES THE NEED
FOR FURTHER INFORMATION AND
STUDY INTO THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE HOUSING
IN THIS TWENTY SIXTEEN ANNUAL
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT?
PRESIDENT OF POTS ON A RECENTLY
LAUNCHED THE STUDENT HOUSING
INITIATIVE FOR THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING FOURTEEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE BAD FOR
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS. BY TWENTY TWENTY.
IT'S TWO YEARS FROM NOW.
I PERSONALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE ON TRACK TO THAT GOAL IF
EVERY CAMPUS IS BUILT SEVEN
HUNDRED NEW BEDS IN THE LAST
YEARS IN ORDER TO MEET ITS
QUOTA.
LIKE BERKELEY HAS.
WE ARE STILL LESS THAN HALF WAY%
TOWARDS OUR GOALS OF THE FILL
THE TWENTY TWENTY PLAN IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
AS YOU SEE INCREASES HOUSING
STOCK ANY DEMANDS IN A ROMAN NEW
HOUSING PROJECTS SHOULD
INCORPORATE PLANS TO HOW
STUDENTS IN NEED OF EMERGENCY
ACCOMMODATIONS.
STAY IN THE UC CAN DEVELOP
DISPLAYS HOUSING FUNDS TO COVER
BASIC NEEDS FOR STUDENTS FACING
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS OR DIE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IF ON CAMPUS HOUSING IS NOT
AVAILABLE AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY FUNDS ALLOWING
CAMPUSES TO SUBSIDIZE RENTS FOR
STUDENTS MOST FINALLY FINANCE
LEAN MEAT.
IN THIS IN ADDITION THERE CAN BE
FURTHER INVESTMENT IN COOPER
HOUSING PROPERTIES WHICH IN HOW
STUDENTS AND MORE FOR THE RENTS.
IN ORDER TO SAVE CALIFORNIA FROM
ITS LOOMING ONE POINT ONE
MILLION COLLEGE DEBT. COLLEGE
DEGREE DEFICIT IN THE FUTURE
HARD CHOICES NEED TO BE MADE
TODAY.
IT IS OBVIOUS WE NEED AN
INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH TO
SOLVING THESE DEEP SEEDED
ISSUES.
WE CAN'T SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
STERN HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS IF
FOR ONLY TACKLING FOOD SECURITY
OR HOUSING OR MENTAL HEALTH
SINGULARITY SINGLING.
OUR SYSTEM IN OUR STATE MUST
WORK COLLECTIVELY ON ADDRESSING
THEM ALL IN ORDER TO ENSURE
SENSE OF COLOR FIRST OR RENT
GENERATION AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
ACHIEVE THEIR DEGREES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
.
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU'VE GIVEN.
CLEARLY. MOST OF OUR CAMPUSES
HAVE OF.
TAKE HIM AT THE CHALLENGE
SERIOUSLY AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
GOOD TO HEAR. ALL I CAN REMEMBER
FOR PROBABLY FOUR YEARS AGO FIVE
YEARS AGO WE WOULDN'T HAVE AS.
THE STATION WITH REGARDS TO
WHAT'S GOING ON OUR CAMPUSES A
WE WOULD STILL BE TALKING ABOUT
COUCHSURFING IS IF THERE'S SOME
WONDERFUL THING TO ENGAGE IN. A
BECAUSE IT PLAYING IT SOUNDS
GOOD.
OR OF STUDENTS WHO LIVE OFF TOP
RAHMAN AND.
AND THINK THAT THAT'S A IT'S
KIND OF A CHOICE THEY MADE
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO GO TO A
CONCERT.
AND IF I CHOSE TO GO TO.
ETOPS RAMAN VERSUS BY REGULAR
OF THE FOOD SO I THINK THE
CONVERSATION CLEARLY SAYS TO US
ALL OVER THE LAST.
OF THREE FOR USE THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATION WE'VE DONE WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE GOTTEN A PROCESS BY
NO MEANS ARE WE COMPLETE. BUT AT
LEAST WE'VE BEGUN THE
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL AS YOU BEGUN
TO SHARE THE INFORMATION AMONGST
YOURSELVES
WHICH IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT NO CAMPUS FEELS ALONE IN
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE THAT IT IS
A A PART OF ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS
THAT ARE THERE AND EVEN SOME OF
OUR PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS ARE
TAKING UP. AND FOLLOWING THROUGH
WITH THE CAMPUS ISSUES WITH
REGARDS TO HOUSING AND FOOD.
WHEN I GO TO THE PRIVATE CAMPUS
IS THEY ARE ALSO WRESTLING WITH
THAT BECAUSE THE DEALING WITH
THE SAME STUDENTS TO I MEAN IT'S
NOT THAT. STUDENTS WHO GO TO
THESE MORE EXPENSIVE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ARE ANY WEALTHIER THAT
NOT THAT THE SAME STUDENTS THAT
ARE COMING. OUT OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN GOING TO UNIVERSITIES
SO I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WE'VE GOT YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND THIS BEGINS THIS GIVES US
GOOD.
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE COMING
LEGISLATIVE YEAR AS TO WHAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS AND HOW WE NEED
TO ADDRESS IT IT'S IMPORTANT WE
UNDERSTAND. WHEN WE CREATE THESE
BILLS THAT.
WE NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU THAT
WAS THE PURPOSE OF HAVING THE
HEARING TODAY THAT SO WE CAN
FIGURE WITH THE FLAWS ARE. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE CAN PASS THE
BILL FOR EBT IT IF WE DON'T.
WITH IF FOLKS AREN'T SAYING SOME
ARE YOU SAYING IT'S REALLY
WORKING WELL ON YOUR CAMPUS YOU
THAT HUNDRED PERCENT
PARTICIPATION. OF THIS IS SAYING
IT'S A STRUGGLE ON OUR SO WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WITH THE
GLITCHES ARE. YOU KNOW WHERE THE
WHERE THE INFORMATION NEEDS TO
GO IN TERMS OF BEING SHARED BUT
BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE HAVE THOSE WHO MAY WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT IF THERE'S ANYONE
THIS IS THE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS IF ANYONE HAS. A
STATEMENT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE OR QUESTION I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU HAVE A MINUTE TO DO IT.
AND SO.
WOULD YOU PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE HERE. AND.
WE WILL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
AND OR CONCERNS AND PLEASE GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND WHERE YOU FROM
WHEN YOU HAVE A MINUTE.
PAULSON THANK YOU.
SUNDAY AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
CHOOSE THE TERRACE AND I SERVICE
THE PRESIDENT OF FOR THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION I'M ALSO
FOURTH YOUR UNDERGRAD AT UC
SANTA CRUZ. SADEQ START BY
THANKING YOU ALL FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO DISCUSS AND TACKLE THE
ISSUES OF BASIC NEED SECURITY.
IT'S ALSO HEART WARMING TO SEE
THAT WILL TO PROSTITUTION IS A
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION OR
TAKING THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
ADDRESS THE INSECURITIES.
STUDENTS ARE FACING TODAY.
I USE CSMA WE'VE ADOPTED A
CAMPAIGN CALLED UC'S SUSTAIN OUR
STUDENTS.
THAT ADDRESSES FOOD AND HOUSING
SECURITIES ALONG WITH THE STIGMA
BEHIND THESE ISSUES.
IT'S CLEAR TO SEE THAT STUDENT
HUNGER AND STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
IS RECOGNIZE AT THE SYSTEM WIDE
LEVEL AND NOW AT THE STATE.
CAMPUSES HAVE OPENED UP FOOD
PANTRIES PORTER STUDENTS THERE
BEGINNING TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
FUNDS FOR STUDENTS IN DIRE NEED.
BUT LIKE SOMEONE MENTIONED
EARLIER THESE ARE ONLY SHORT
TERM SOLUTIONS.
THAT'S WHERE THE STIGMA BEHIND
BASICALLY SECURITY STUDENT
SHOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE ENOUGH
TO ASK FOR THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO SUCCEED ACADEMICALLY AND
THE STATE TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY TO SUCH RESOURCES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
OKAY.
SYNDICATES DE ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR HOLDING THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT MEETING. WE'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
CONTINUING EFFORTS ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO
REALLY ADDRESS BASIC NEEDS AS WE
KNOW AND IT'S MUCH MORE THAN ON
COMPLETION IT'S ABOUT THE WHOLE
ENTIRE STUDENT AND SUPPORTING
THEM IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO MENTION THAT
FACT IS.
SUPPORTING A BILL OR HOLDING A
BILL A BETWEEN NINE THIRTY THREE
OFFERED BY AND. AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA RELATED
TO.
BUILT BRIDGING THAT THE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
COUNTIES WHICH WE SEE AS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
OKAY YES IT AFTERNOON AYE DAVID
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION.
WEBER IN THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE PARTICULAR
DOCTOR WEBER FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE YOU AUTHORSHIP OF
THE SENATE BILL TO FOURTEEN.
AND JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT.
WE THE COMMISSION ARE FULLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH SEGMENTS STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WE'VE HEARD
FROM TODAY ON THEM ALLEVIATING
THESE ISSUES THROUGH THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM WHENEVER
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OKAY I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
OF THE COMMENTS THAT SLOW MOAN
IS BACK IF YOU HAVE ANY.
PARTING COMMENTS.
I SO I THINK YOU ALL I KNOW THIS
WELCOME TO OUR LIFE RIGHT IN AND
OUT.
I THINK YOU ALL AT FOR YOUR WORK
FOR YOUR ON GOING WORK AND I I
THINK THAT WHAT YOU'RE BRINGING
TO US IS PARTICULARLY HELPFUL.
ON AS WE IN THE LEGISLATURE
TRIED TO IDENTIFY NOT JUST THE
NEEDS THE HOW TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS.
DATIN THAT DRIVE US TO MEET
THESE UNMET NEEDS FOR STUDENTS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT
PARTICULARLY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WORKING AND WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE PARTICULARLY WHAT
THE POTENTIAL ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. AND COULD BE IN.
BIG AND WE KNOW THAT.
STUDENTS ALONE AREN'T THE ONLY
ONES FACING AND SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES OUR COMMUNITY IT'S
IT'S BIGGER THAN THE UNIVERSITY
LIFE BUT I THINK IT'S BEEN
EXACERBATED. ON IN THE
UNIVERSITY LIFE AND IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT I SAW
ON IN MY TIME I MEAN HIGHER AND
AS I'M SURE.
YOU HAVE DOCTOR ROBERT DID AS
WELL SO THINK YOU.
WELL I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR COMING AND PARTICIPATING
THIS LET ME FIRST OF ALL THANK
MY STAFF SOMETIMES. YOU KNOW
WITH THE GIVE YEAH YEAH.
TIFFANY BOY IS A MY FELLOW WHO
YOU HERE WITH ME.
A GRADUATE OF.
CAL STATE SAN MARCOS
AND.
AN AMAZING FELLOW AND SHE'S
TAKEN WAS CHARGED ONE THINK
HARRISON HIND HARRISON IS
SOMEWHERE AROUND THE HARRISON IS
ACTUALLY GRADUATING FROM MED
SCHOOL. AND HE'S BEEN IN MY
OFFICE NOW FOR THE LAST.
MAYBE FIVE OR SIX MONTHS DOING
AMAZING WORK ON HEALTH ISSUES
FOR US AND HE WAS HERE TODAY
SETTING UP SOME OF THOSE SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE TO HEAR SOME.
AND THEN ROY KAUFMAN IS IN THE
BACK TO ALWAYS MOVING AND
GROOVING AND TAKING CARE OF
THINGS SOLELY CENTRAL.
SO I THINK THOSE THREE THEY TOOK
THE LEAD WITH THE BY OF THE
STAFF AND LENDING SUPPORT MY
HAVE AN AMAZING STAFF OF YOU'VE
EVER WORKED WITH THEM. OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY OF. ALL KEEP
ME. MOVING NOW BUT THEY ARE.
THEY THEY BRING UP THE CRITICAL
ISSUES WELL THINK ALSO SET UP A
YOUNG MAN NAMED SCOTT.
MATSUMOTO SCOTT WAS OF MY FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS WORKED IN OUR
OFFICE ONE AS A VOLUNTEER AND
THEN AS A STAFFER. WHO REALLY A
USED TO OF? BASICALLY WAS IN
CHARGE OF ALL OF THE UC CAMPUS
CLIMATE COMMITTEES AND HE WAS
VERY AND STILL IS VERY COMMITTED
TO IT HE'S STILL IN THE HOUSE HE
WORKS IN THIS BUILDING. BODIES
IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE NOW AS A
CONSULTANT HE'S BEEN ELEVATED TO
ANOTHER LEVEL AS A AS A OUT
CONSULTANT FOR. THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE BUT DOES HE BROUGHT
THESE ISSUES FORWARD INTO A LOT
OF THE EARLY RESEARCH AND AND
WORK WITH CAMPUS TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW I'VE TAKEN UP THIS
ISSUE FOR THE LAST THREE FOUR
YEARS ACTUALLY THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. AND.
AND WE'VE SEEN NOT ONLY.
BEFORE WE HAD A SELECT
COMMITTEE WE TOOK UP THE ISSUE
OF EBT CARDS ON CAMPUSES AND I
HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT TO A YOUNG
WOMAN WHO WAS A STUDENT MIND AT
SAN DIEGO STATE.
WHO CAME TO WORK ON MY CAMPAIGN
IN TWENTY TWELVE WHEN I RAN FOR
THE ASSEMBLY? AND SHE WAS THE
ONE WHO INTRODUCED THE QUESTION
OF WHY WE CAN'T HAVE THE BT ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. OF SHE WAS
INVOLVED WITH MY DEPARTMENT WAS
CHAIR OF THE PART OF AFRICA
STUDIES AND SHE BEGAN DOING
RESEARCH AS SHE WAS OF ONE OF
THE STUDENTS OF. IN MY CLASS
TING RESEARCH A WHEN I WAS
ELECTED SHE CAME TO THE CAPITOL.
DID A A SEMESTER KIND OF
INTERNSHIP HERE AT THE CAPITOL
WAS SHE WAS GRADUATING FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE. TOTALLY FOCUSED ON
THAT BECAUSE SHE WAS A RECIPIENT
SHE HAD SHE WAS A SEPARATE OF
CAL FRESH.
AND SHE ROOM AND AND SHE MADE ME
AWARE HOW COMPLICATED IT WAS TO
LIVE WHILE WITH CAO FRESH ON
CAMPUSES ESPECIALLY CAMPUSES
CROWDED THE SAN DIEGO STATE. AND
SO FOR HER TO PARKER CAR AND BE
VIEWED TAKING CLASSES THEN HAVE
TO LEAVE THE CAMPUS IN ORDER TO.
PURCHASE SOME FOOD.
BECAUSE SHE COULDN USER EBT
CARD ON CAMPUS.
AND LETS YOU BUY JUNK FOOD AND
SHE DIDN'T WANT JUNK.
AND SO SHE'D HAVE TO GET IN HER
CAR TO GO OAK TO REST OF
SOMEPLACE SO SHE COULD GET A HOT
MEAL WITH A RESTAURANT MEAL
PROGRAM. SO SHE MADE ME AWARE OF
THAT AND IT WAS A SQUARE BATTLE
WE GET OFF AT THE FIRST PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BUT EBT CARD AND IT
DIDN'T AND WE COULDN'T GET IT
OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE JUST WEREN'T
READY FOR THEY DID UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
AND I AND I UNIVERSITIES
RESISTED.
THEY RESISTED VEHEMENTLY
BECAUSE THEY SAID IT WOULD COST
TOO MUCH IT EXTREME PRICE TAG ON
IT OZONE SOMEONE OF LIKE A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CAMPUS. IN ORDER TO GET AN
EBT CARD MACHINE.
FORTUNATELY AND AND AND THAT'S
WHAT THE NUMBER THAT WAS GIVEN
TO US AND SO BECAME IMPASSABLE
BUS ATTEMPT TO IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE OF THE COST FACTOR WHILE
THE CAMPUSES WELL THANK GOD FOR
HOME BOTH STATE I THINK IT WAS.
WHO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM AND
TOLD US IT COST TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM WHICH
REALLY BLEW ALL OF OUR FINANCIAL
PEOPLE?
OUT OF THE WATER
TO SAY THEY HAVE BEEN TELLING US
TO ON A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND UP WERE PER CAMPUS AND HERE
HUMBOLDT STATES IT WE DID IT FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS SO
THAT HE'LL THAT IDEA. AND OPEN
UP THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE
AND GET THESE EBT CARDS ON
CAMPUSES BECAUSE THE INFORMATION
WE WERE BEING GIVEN WAS FLAWED
WOULD A CAMPUS HAD A DESIRE TO
DO IT. THEY DID IT AND I'M NOT
SURE WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE WAS
GOING TO DO A TWENTY THOUSAND US
I JUST ASSUME THEY WANT TO HIRE
SOME NEW EMPLOYEES JUST DON'T
OVERLOOK THE MACHINE. BUT.
BUT THE INTERESTING THING IS
THAT THAT OPEN UP AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US AND WE BEGAN TO LOOK AT
THE DATA IN THE RESEARCH
CONCERNING.
FOOD INSECURITIES AND I CAN SAY
THAT I HAVE JUST BEEN TRULY
AMAZED AND BLESSED BY THE WHAT
YOU HAVE DONE THUS FAR AND
TOTALLY COMMITTED TO CONSTANTLY
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES AS YOU
BRING THOSE BILLS FORWARD.
THIS HOUSE THIS THIS ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE ARE VERY VERY
COMMITTED TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
AT FIRST LIKE I SAID IT WAS A
STRUGGLE IN TWENTY TWELVE
THIRTEEN TO GET BILLS OUT TO GET
THEM HURT TO HAVE PEOPLE.
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS GOING ON NOW
WHEN THE BILL COMES FOR LIKE THE
ONE I HAVE NOW THAT'S OUT THERE.
IT IS EMBRACED BY MORE THAN JUST
SHIRLEY WEBER AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY ARE
BASICALLY AUTHORING PIECES OF
LEGISLATION DEALING WITH THE
ISSUES OF. FOOD INSECURITY IN
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR STUDENTS
BOB AND SO I'M REALLY BUT AND
AND THEN THEY'RE IMPRESSED BY
WHAT YOU'VE DONE. YOU HAVE TAKEN
WHAT WE SAID MAKE SHOULD HAPPEN
AND REALLY WHAT THE REALIZADA TO
TAKE IT TO ANOTHER LEVEL. AND
I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU DIDN'T ASK
US TO DO THAT BECAUSE IF WE HAD
DONE THAT. IF WE HAD SET UP FOOD
BANKS. PANTRIES IN YOUR CAMPUSES
ANYONE WHO GOT A CRACKER WOULD
HAVE TO GIVE US THEIR NAME THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. TWO OR
THREE OF THEIR CHILDREN A
WHATEVER BECAUSE WE WOULD HAVE
REGULATED SO MUCH TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU WERE TRULY TRULY HUNGRY
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A HUNDRED
TESTS.
AND YOU HAVE DONE BETTER THAN
THAT YOU HAVE SAID AS A CAMPUS
WE BELIEVE IN EACH OTHER. WE
TRUST EACH OTHER.
AND WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE REAL
ISSUES AND THAT WE SHOULD NOT
HUMILIATE PEOPLE IN THE PROCESS
OF GIVING THEM SUPPORT AND HELP.
AND I HAVE LOVED.
I HAVE BEEN SO AMAZED BECAUSE WE
HAVE ONE HEARING THE SAN DIEGO
SOMEONE ON PANEL ASKED WELL HOW
OFTEN CAN A PERSON COME DO YOU
MEAN YOU LET HIM COME MORE THAN
ONCE A MONTH. AND EAGLE WELL YET
THEY'RE STILL HUNGRY THEY NEED
FOOD MORE THAN ONCE A MONTH AND
SO IT WAS INTERESTING THAT
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE JUDGE
GENEROSITY AS AS STUDENTS AND AS
PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH STUDENTS.
WAS MUCH GREATER THAN OURS AS A
STATE AND SO WHERE WE CAN GIVE
THE TO ON A FIFTY THOUSAND
WHATEVER IF WE HAD GIVEN IT.
THAT IT PROBABLY WOULD NOT HAVE
GONE TO SO WITH WE IF WE HAD
ADMINISTERED IT WOULD NOT HAVE
GONE AS FAR BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
HIRE SOMEBODY TO TO AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO ADMINISTER
IT AND WHAT YOU'VE DONE IS TAKEN
THE RESOURCES AND MULTIPLY IT
AND MADE IT REALLY COME ALIVE
I'M REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF WHAT
YOU'VE DONE. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES
YOU'VE GIVEN US SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS DO NOT HESITATE
TO SEND MORE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
OUR OFFICE. THAT IF YOU FIND
THIS AND CHALLENGES TO SOME
GLITCHES MAKE SURE YOU GET THAT
TO US BECAUSE WE IN THIS HOUSE
AND THAT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE. ARE VERY COMMITTED TO
THIS ISSUE WE KNOW WE CAN'T
SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS WE GOT
GREAT PROBLEMS OF HOUSING IN THE
LARGER COMMUNITY WHICH I'M SURE
YOU REALIZE. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL POVERTY OF ANY
STATE WITH ALL THE WEALTH THAT
WE HAVE THE STATE WE HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL POVERTY.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON THOSE
THINGS IN A MATTER HOW WE
CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON WE ARE A LONG WAY FROM BEING
IN A PUBLIC POSITION. WILL WE
BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE WHO WORKS
FULL TIME SHOULD NOT LIVE IN
POVERTY AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE
PHILOSOPHIES OF OUR FORMER
SPEAKER TONI ATKINS IS STILL ARE
PHILOSOPHY TODAY. THAT NO PERSON
SHOULD WORK FULL TIME IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND STILL BE
IN POVERTY AND WE KNOW THAT THEY
ARE AND SO WERE CUT CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A BUT I REALLY THANK
YOU FOR COMING TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THIS INFORMATION IT
IS EXTREMELY VALUABLE TO US AND
YOU ARE VERY VALUABLE TO YOU
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE THIS
MEANS THERE